- Hey guys, do you like charity?
(all laughing)
- Gamers, we have a big announcements.
We are going to be doing
a 24-hour Charity Stream.
You heard that, right.
(Joey jubilating)
- So the whole situation
kind of messed up right now
for all sorts of different reasons.
So we thought we would come together,
stream for 24 hours to support
Doctors Without Borders
on our Twitch channel.
twitch.tv/trashtastepodcast.
What are we gonna be doing
on that stream though,
is the question you're probably asking.
- Games.
(chuckling)
We have a bunch of
different things planned,
including guests, games and humiliation.
And Joey will eat a ghost
pepper, maybe who knows,
if we raise enough money.
- Maybe.
- Maybe, maybe.
- So make sure to open up that wallet
to make sure that Joey can suffer.
- That's the reason we're doing it.
(men laughing)
- I'm not here for the charity.
I'm here to make Joey suffer.
- So the event will be starting 11:00 AM,
Japan time, on the 19th of March.
If you live anywhere else in the world,
here are some just basic time
zones, that hopefully Munah
is putting on screen right now.
If not,
- 6PM PST.
- Look it up yourself on time converter.
But yeah, it'll be going on 24 hours
and we'll hopefully change
the world for the better,
even for a little bit.
- And on with the episode.
(burping)
- What?
- Why do you have to do that
on the mic?
- Why not?
- Pretty sure that's how down
with the Sickness starts.
- Yeah, it is, yeah.
(burping)
Oh.
- The way that kick off very quickly.
- You can't, you can't right?
Not for that.
- Hm, I thought I was too perfect
in my impression of Disturbed.
(bright cheerful music)
- [Connor] Welcome to this
episode of Trash Taste.
And today we're gonna be
comparing our musical tastes.
- Our trash taste in music, or good taste,
who knows, maybe one of us
has good taste in music.
- And I've five.
- Said no one watching this.
(all laughing)
- Unfortunately we can't plead the fifth
in Trash Taste episodes,
which I would love to do,
cause I don't really know how
to describe music very well.
- Okay, I've.
- We've established that
very early on in the
Trash Taste wall, right?
- Yeah, see, we've
established that with Connor,
but, I also have been shitting myself
with the thought of this episode
and especially when it came
to like picking my choices.
One, it was super difficult
because I didn't know like,
I didn't know how to describe why I liked,
like the picks that I picked.
I just know that they were important to me
at a time in my life.
- We gotta see why we like it.
- Ah?
- Fuck.
I'm fucked, I'm fucked.
- Well.
- Yeah.
- I guess like, on what
basis did you pick it?
'Cause it's like, I guess,
Garnt was saying that,
it was an important,
like important artist in your life, right?
- Yeah.
- Mine is all also kind of
based on that, in a sense.
- Yeah.
(Joey chuckling)
- Okay, actually, first question,
how did you boys, what method did you use
to like pick your artist?
- I've said, I've said.
- I dunno, I dunno.
- Song they sang good I put down.
- Yeah, Connor's like,
Connor's method is,
- Song good.
- Do I remember the artist's name?
I'll put it down.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Cause actually like, my
biggest difficulty, right.
Is that I like a lot of songs,
but I dunno if I like a lot of artists,
- Why?
- I like certain songs
from certain artists, but I feel like,
I'm more like, I get into genres of music
or like I get into like a certain genre
then more than I get into
this one specific artist
or this one specific band.
And if I do, it's like
very, very, very rare.
- I think that's pretty normal.
- It's like the food,
It's like, "I like French food.
"I don't like all French food"
So it's like, that's the way I see it.
It's like, "but I do
like all Mexican food.
"It's pretty fucking good."
So I guess also I'll say
that's kinda how I view it,
or how I see it.
for me it was like,
I couldn't just like reach
into the nether and grab a band
because I'm sure if I did that,
I'm sure there'd be like
a million other bands
that I just completely forgot about.
So I was like, "all right,
I'll split it into genres."
I like metal music, fuck."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
That didn't make it any easier.
- I'm like SpongeBob writing
the, my first fourth.
My first fourth picks.
I'm like so confident like, "oh this one.
"Oh, that one.
"Okay, oh this one.
"Okay, wait, what else do I listen to?
"Oh shit."
- Yeah, yeah,
I literally went.
Okay, we had our first
four, five picks that was
easy he came to our head.
- Yeah.
- And then I went through
my Spotify to try and see
if I could narrow down anything
else that I could talk about
or was important to me.
And the more I scrolled,
the more I'm just like,
what the fuck is my music taste?
What is actually, this
like collection of songs
that I've put together
that defines who I am.
I tried to psychoanalyze
this and I'm like,
"I don't know
"what this fucking person like."
- That's what I love about doing
these three by three episodes.
Is that, more so than our
audience trying to figure out
what our tastes are,
we find out what our own tastes are.
We truly are.
- All right,
I do really you wanna change
some of my picks, but we'll go with it.
We'll go with it.
- We'll go with it.
Well, some of my picks were
like, I chose one band,
but it was more of just like,
I wanted to pick one band
just to,
- Talk about
which you don't know?
several bands that I
want to put in this spot.
- Get those excuses out now, Garnt.
Get them out.
- Yeah.
- Get 'em out, set 'em up,
set up the, set 'em up.
(conversing)
Oh this one?
- Yeah, yeah.
But this one is what I often,
that one time that I saved,
he loved this song.
(Joey laughing)
I also love it.
- Yeah, I dunno.
I guess it's been,
it's like, now that I think about it,
I have like such a different
relationship to music
than I do to like other forms of media,
I have like really games that
I could talk about forever.
About like, why I've really
fucking liked this game.
Same thing with movies, same
thing with anime, obviously.
But with music's always
been this one enigma for me,
because music's just been this one thing
where I like certain
things, I dunno why like it,
I just like it.
- It's because most people,
when they listen to music,
(Connor whispering)
(all laughing)
I just like it.
No explanation.
(all laughing)
- Sorry, that was terrible.
- I think it's just because most people
when they're listen to music,
don't think that deeply about
what they're listening to.
- No, no.
- There isn't a guy
that like runs into
the room and he's like,
"Explain what you are
listening to right now."
He's like, "ah, the drums are good."
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like,
when someone's like,
"what's your tasting music?"
You can just be like, "ah, metal."
You don't, too bad.
- Yeah, yeah.
And then he was like, "okay."
And then that's it, right?
- Yeah, when people ask me
what on a taste music is,
I'm just like, "ah."
- Yes.
- Yes, I like so, I like everything.
I like,
- I like songs.
- I hate being that guy who just goes,
"I like a bit of everything."
'Cause it's just like the generic answer,
but I literally don't know
how to answer that question
aside from, "Yeah, I like
a bit of everything."
- Should we stop giving
excuses to ourselves,
and just get on with it?
- Go on,
this is it.
- All right, are we gonna do trash boxing?
- Bring him back trash.
- As per tradition.
- Yes.
- All right, so I guess,
- I don't want Joey to go first.
- I don't wanna go first either.
- Because I don't want Joey,
- I don't wanna follow Joey.
- I don't wanna have Joey.
(laughing)
Like give him this, his
fucking presentation,
this PowerPoint with animations.
- I don't.
- Why he likes
this kind of call.
- My goal for this episode
is to not be that pretentious music song.
- No, we need you to be
that pretentious music.
- I don't want to be
- Because you need to
counter rights me and
Connor going, "Oh, boo, boo.
"I like the beeps and the boos."
And I'm being like, "Well,
the voice sounded nice.
"I like the voice."
And I'm just like,
- I like the voice.
- Oh, it's Connor first.
- It's Connor.
Okay, perfect, alright.
- This is gonna be tough.
- All right.
- This is like my mom's gonna walk in
and there's a shit everywhere.
And I'm like, "Listen, I can explain.
"This has a reason."
- All right, go on, man.
- This is a weird
three by three, I think.
- All right.
- Some of them you'll expect,
some of them you won't
or so I chose, I try
to choose a funny image
for some of them.
- I can think of at least three bands.
- That's good, that's good.
- Yeah.
- It can't be actually, can you really?
- I thought only one.
- No, no.
There's at least,
- I think of definitely one.
- No, I can think of at least three.
- Aright, we'll find out.
- All right.
- Let's find out.
(laughing)
- [Connor] Do like the initial
I chose for the Weeknd?
(all laughing)
- Where did you get the
image of the Weeknd?
- That's like the famous picture.
This is a weird one.
I can explain
- Yeah,
I got the three that I thought.
- Okay, that's good.
- What was the three that you thought.
- [Joey] I knew Daft
Punk, Weeknd and Tempo.
That's good then.
- I knew
he was gonna put that on them.
- [Connor] But Joey knows
I love Tempo and Parlor.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Joey knows that and Daft.
- And Daft Punk.
- Yeah.
- Okay, I put Bo Burnham on the left.
- Yeah, I got by Burnham.
- Okay, yeah, yeah.
That shouldn't surprise me.
- Anri.
- Do you know,
this is kind of like, we'll get into this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right, right.
- This is more about city pop in general.
- Okay, okay.
- We'll talk about that.
- I don't know, I don't
think I know the rest.
- This is Parcels.
- Parcels?
- Yeah, so they kind of not well known,
but it's very similar vibes to Daft Punk
plus this is a Breakbot over there.
You know, Breakbot?
- Yeah.
you know Breakbot.
- Yeah, I know their song though.
- You know the "Baby I'm yours?"
The ladies and gentlemen, we got 'em song.
- Oh, that's that's Breakbot?
- That's Breakbot.
- Okay.
- But I knew,
the rest their songs are amazing.
- Yeah.
- Okay,
I've listened to some of their music.
I was like, their songs fucking slap.
- I don't know if I know them.
- You know them.
- You've definitely heard the meme.
- You know, you know the meme song?
- Probably.
(Garnt blabbering)
- Okay, yeah that's nice.
Yeah, that's nice.
- No, no, have you ever
listened to that song
without it being base boosted?
- No.
I only know that song bass boosted.
- Well, okay.
So I mean, there's not
much I can, I kinda.
The band I listen to the most.
It's definitely these five
are the ones I listen to right now.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I love The Weeknd.
He also drop the new album,
and I fucking love that album.
- Yeah, that's a great album.
- I guess, who do I
wanna talk about first?
Who's should I talk about first?
Who'd you want me to talk about first?
- I guess you've talked about,
- Who's the parcels?
- Parcels?
- Yeah, yeah.
Let's talk about Parcels,
cause I don't think gone,
- So they've a band right now, I believe.
Okay, this is gonna be hard to talk about.
Cause I don't know a lot
about a lot of these people.
All I know is that I play
their music an awful lot.
- Okay.
- I think they're a band
that is based in Germany.
I don't think they are German.
But they live in Germany
and they do kind of like,
it's very funk, but also,
ah how do I describe music to people?
I only know people.
- Because like the guy,
the guy in that,
- I can literally see
Connor's brain cells committing suicide.
As he's like trying to process this.
- I don't know how to explain.
- I'm not gonna lie.
I looked at this picture of Parcels
and the guy at the back in the middle
looks like George Harrison.
- Yeah, yeah,
he's weird, right?
- Yeah, they look like Beatles
if they were around today.
- I don't know how to explain it.
It's like they don't.
I don't know.
- [Munah] Parcels are an
Australian electropop.
- Oh, they're are Aussies.
- I like electropop, man.
- Aussies?
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, okay, okay.
- I like electropop.
- Let's go.
There we go.
- Electropop.
- If you know, a lot of
the things you can see,
like the influence of like,
if you look Daft Punk in the middle
and be kind of like
little parts of Daft Punk,
they've experimented in.
That's probably where I
like, cause it's like,
I think my favorite Daft
Punk album is Discovery,
which I've put there.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- But I don't think there's many songs
of Daft Punk I don't like.
Given the first album is
probably the one I don't like
the most, cause it's very
like more experimental
as opposed to the other stuff they did.
- Yeah, it's all more
like rudimentary for sure.
- And a lot of, some of the
songs in the first album,
I cannot remember the
name of the first album,
the one with the AM on the front of it.
Literally, I think it
might just be called AM.
- I mean, I feel like I
only started listening
to Daft punk after like,
was it the Homework album?
Is that the one?
- Homework was their first.
- I'm not sure of this.
- Homework was the first one
where I properly got
into Daft Punk as well.
- I think that's why most
people got into Daft Punk.
Either Homework or Discovery.
- Well, I think it was like,
I think the first big hit was
Around The World, wasn't it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That was what put them
on the map my friend.
- Which is the most
repetitive song in existence.
- Is it a AM, FM, is that the album?
- [cameraman] About Daft Punk or?
- Yeah, what's the album name?
You have to fact check
me on a lot of these.
- We're gonna need a
lot of fact check here.
- Yeah, we're good.
- We're good.
- Everyone behind the camera check time,
fact check time, all right?
- We're gonna find the facts.
- We need like seven facts checkers.
- [Cameraman] Parcels
collaborated with Daft Punk
on their 2017 single or not.
- I didn't even know that.
- Oh, there you go.
That's probably where the.
- That's probably where, why?
'Cause a lot of these
our artists that I find
that I've no idea who they are,
it's like YouTube recommends me.
- Yeah, you know who I'm surprised
is not on your three by three.
- Who?
- Joji.
- Joji?
I don't listen to Joji that much.
- Every time I go to your
house, you're playing Joji.
- That is true, that is true.
- I've played a lot of Joji,
but I think I had faces of Joji.
I like Joji a lot.
I like Joji a lot, but.
- That just sounds like
a band faces of Joji.
- I love Joji's music, but
there's only four songs
that I actually listen to.
The rest of the album,
I don't really like.
I think at least for the first five,
I've listened to like everything,
from Tempo and Parlor, Weeknd,
Daft Punk, Breakbot, Parcels.
I've listened to like everything.
And so the Parcels,
Daft Punk and Breakbot,
I can just put on their albums.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Any song and I'll have a good time.
And I'm like, "This is great."
Like if I'm in a car, those
are the three I'm playing.
- So this is all like recent taste, then.
Or as,
- Within the past five years,
unfortunately my tastes
haven't really changed much
in the past six years.
It's kind of like I have phases
where I go into something else,
but it always comes back
to that type of music.
- What did you listen
to when you were a kid?
- Yeah.
- This is a good question.
Well, right in the bottom
bottom right, is Biffy Clyro.
Do you know Biffy Claro?
- No idea.
- No idea who Biffy Clyro is.
- I don't know but that
album covers is cool.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So Biffy Clyro is a Scottish rock band.
- Okay.
- And they've done a.
- Biffy Clyro.
(men laughing)
- I'd say un-Scottish.
- Watched it for Foo Fighters a few times.
- Oh, okay.
- So if you like Foo Fighters.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And you want a more Scott
version of Foo Fighters.
- Oh.
- I might be butchering
and doing an absolute
disservice to Biffy Clyro,
but I liked Foo Fighters a
lot and the way I found them
is that a lot of my friends
in school really liked
Foo Fighters and when we were growing up,
that's the kind of stuff they liked.
And then I got into Biffy Clyro from that.
And I went to watched them live.
That was the first concert I ever went to.
- A Biffy Clyro concert?
- Yeah, it was amazing.
- Oh, fuck it.
- I loved it so much.
And I don't know.
I would say this is a
good album to listen to.
They had the really famous
one that came out before this.
I can't remember the name of it.
It's got like two big
colors on the front of it.
(man chuckles)
It's got the name of it.
- Do they singing like a
Scottish accent as well.
- Yes, so that's what I love about them,
- Oh, hell, yeah.
- Is that like,
you know how sometimes a
lot of bands whether they're
from Scotland, but they
just sound American somehow.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But it's actually like,
"Hey, yo, how yo doin?"
(blabbering, laughing)
Something like that, sorry.
- [Cameraman] Something
that I'm only looking for
is only revolution.
- That's it only revolution.
- [Cameraman] Daft Punk
first album was Homework.
- Yeah, Homework was the first album.
- Homework, oh shit, I
thought AM came first, my bad.
- Okay.
- I'm fake that much.
- So it was their first album?
- [Cameraman] They've
got Random Access Memory,
I thinking about RAM.
- No, no.
- Random Access Memory,
- That's probably like
an EP or something.
- Yeah, it might have been.
- EP first album.
- Oh, my bad then.
Yeah, I must have.
- That's what I want
more bands to do though.
Because the one thing I
like sing in the accent
of the country that they're from.
- You should, I think you
quite like Biffy Clyro.
- Because that's what I love about,
that's what I love about
Proclaimers, right?
Cause like when they
sing The 500 Mile song,
they couldn't sound any
more fucking Scottish
than that song, right?
- Yeah, I find it so weird
when I hear an artist,
and you hear, you hear them sing.
And then you hear them speak
and there is such a dissonance
between how they sing and how they speak.
I remember one of the first
time I heard Adele speak.
(Joey laughing)
And it's like the most Northern accent.
- You're British, why you surprised?
You're British.
- Because she doesn't sound anything
like that which she sing.
- Wow, probably for good reason.
(Garnt laughing)
Could you imagine an Adele song
in the accent that she speaks?
- Oh my.
Like there's no way she would've blown up.
Cause no one would've
been able to understand
what she was saying.
- Put your body to the rain.
(all laughing)
- But like,
- Oh, Adele getting dragged to the media.
- Rolling into deep.
(both laughing)
Rolling in the deep I am.
Like that she wouldn't
have walked off, I'm sorry.
- No, cause it's like, cause I had no idea
she was British until I heard her speak.
And she was, then I was like,
"Oh this is the most Northern person
"I've ever heard speak in my life, and,"
- I feel a lot of Australian
artists are like that too.
Like Sia for example,
is the most Australian sound
- I'm not sure I listen
to Sia a lot.
- Posts in an interviews.
But when she sings, everyone
thinks she's America.
We lose our accents for some
reason, I don't know why.
- Yeah, we can't like, I find it hard to,
do an accent, but it's not hard to.
For some reason it's less hard
to sing an accent, I dunno.
It's weird, right?
- I find it easier
to sing in an American accent
than I do speak in an American accent.
- I don't understand
at all, how it works.`
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
I don't how accents work.
I don't know how it works
when you sing though.
It's a bit different register.
- I think that's why when
I hear an accent in a song,
it immediately like just
sticks out to me, I guess.
Cause you always hear like
the neutral American accent
with like a lot of songs.
So when you hear an accent
that is just anything
that's not like the stereotypical
neutral American accent,
it immediately just sticks out in my mind.
- That's what, that's what I
want more artists to do though.
Cause otherwise everyone's just
gonna sound the same, right?
And it's like, if there's
the best way to make you
as an artist stand out, is
to just sound different.
Like just sing in a different accent.
Cause then immediately you'll be like,
you'll listen to a Biffy Clyro song
and you'll be like, "Oh
they sound Scottish,
"must be a Biffy Clyro song."
- Yeah, I mean they're very, very Scottish
when you hear them.
It's fun, I love it.
- Could you imagine
if Biffy Clyro, obviously
I don't know Biffy Clyro.
But you said they kind of
sound similar to Foo Fighters?
- Well, I'd say it's
kind of in the same vein.
- Okay.
- Its kind of feeling
of the way they sing song.
- So would you say that if per chance
the Biffy Clara lead singer.
- Dies?
- Sang in an accent
- No, it wouldn't
even sound same.
- like Dave Grohl,
then it would sound
like Foo Fighters or no?
- No, I don't know.
That's weird because the
songs are so Scottish,
if you listen to them, you'll,
I think you might like them.
They kinda seem like your
kind of band actually.
You love Foo Fighters, right?
- Yeah, I love Foo Fighters.
- Yeah, I think you'll probably like that.
- I like Foo Fighters as well.
- But you'll probably like them as well,
if you like Scottish
kind of my take on it.
Again, I must be offending
like Biffy massive fan.
- Massive Biffy Clyro fans?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So shake your hands
like this.
- But like that's the only way
that I know cause I'm,
I don't understand how to talk about music
like a normal human being.
So this is the only way I
can imagine explaining it.
But also it was like the first album,
I ever bought out of like physical,
I think I only ever bought
like three albums in my life.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- And I think this was the first one.
- Oh.
- I think after that, I think about it.
I don't think I've ever bought an album.
- I love this so much.
I remember I loaded that onto my PC.
I don't know I put it on my Xbox.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And you could play the albums on Xbox
while playing another game.
I would open up that
fucking (blabbers) menu.
The fucking big one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I will press play, the
volume was just dreadfully
like not managed correctly.
So I'd play Modern Warfare two
and just I thought that
I want you to feel it.
No, like that and I was like, it's great.
Its awesome.
- No, I had a CD player
like the fucking chunky.
- No, I had one of those two CD.
- You know, what's the
first album I bought on CD.
- What?
- Fucking Simple Plan?
- Great.
(clapping)
- Classic Joey, classic Joey.
- That album slaps, I don't
care what anyone says.
- Man, but yeah,
I have a Tame Impala as
well, I love to Tame Impala.
My favorite album is the
Slow Rush, not the other one
that everyone, that you see everywhere
and everyone talks about it.
- Oh, Currents.
- Yeah, that's the one
that everyone praises.
- Slow Rush is a good album.
- I love Slow Rush.
Breathe Deeper is not my
favorite song for Tame Impala.
I love that fucking song.
- Great song.
- I don't know, driving
to Tame Impala is like
another level of enjoying it.
I don't know why.
- Have you listened to
his side project Pond?
- No.
- It like Tame Impala you'll like that.
It's just,
- I probably pretty will.
- It's just Tame Impala but harder.
- Well, YouTube recommend
it to me, I'll find out.
- Probably not.
- You're right.
Basically, that's how my music is decided.
Have the algorithm gods
decided it's fit for me.
(men laughing)
If so, yes I listen.
But unfortunately, sometimes
it recommends me artists,
there's like one song I really like.
And I check out the other
stuff and I'm like (blabbers)
- Yeah, there's lots of artists like that.
- It's like that happens like that.
- Who is the one on the
left, above The Burner?
- Oh this is, you know them.
Snail's House.
- Oh, Snail's House, okay.
- Oh, is that Snail's House?
- Yeah, I love Snail's House.
- Snail's House is good.
- Again, no lyrics, let's go.
- Yeah,
I didn't recognize the art.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I love Snail's House.
It's probably like if I
can encapsulate all my,
I guess I don't even
if it is a disservice,
to call it Weib Music?
It's kind of like.
- No, it is Pond
- Weib nostalgic gaming site.
- It's subculture of like Weib.
- He's half Japanese, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like Weib nerdy shit.
- I like how,
- Weib nerdy shit.
- I like how this one makes me feel.
I like this one.
- Yeah.
- There was a phase in my life
where I feel like I listen.
- How does it make you feel.
- Happy.
I wanna say happy emotion.
- So there was like,
before I moved to Japan,
I wanna say I listened
to this for like, God,
like a whole year straight.
I must listening.
- Were you prepping
your Japan visit with some.
- With?
Before I even started the move to Japan,
I was listening to them
and then weirdly it was like.
- Fun?
- Yeah, I just love this album a lot.
Not this album, sorry.
I love all of his songs.
- Yeah.
- Absolute all bangers.
All kind of different moods
even though like it's the same style,
I like how it, it doesn't
always feel the same.
There's a bunch of variations.
Shout out to Snail's House, banging.
If you like anime music
or anything like that
or like electronic,
you're probably like this,
it's really good.
- Yeah I call, I call
this genre, a Weep Call.
- Weep Call.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's Wee.
- It is, it's like Weep Call.
- It's Weep Daft Punk?
- Yeah.
- Question mark.
I don't know.
- Weep Call.
- There's no, there's no lyrics.
It's life.
- It's just a name for it.
It is Weep Call.
- It's Weep Call.
- Weep Call.
- It feels like a rollercoaster you're on.
That you're not on it, you're not on it.
But you are a rollercoaster.
How describe?
How the fuck do I describe music?
How do you do this?
How's Anthony Fantano do this.
How, what the fuck is he doing?
- Just a lot of adjectives.
- What?
- This is like how I describe this music.
It's like if you go to an artist
if you go to an artist alley
in any convention and put that,
and take that experience, put
that in the genre of music,
that is like,
- We can, yeah.
- That's Weep Call basically, right?
- Pretty much.
- It's not anime.
- You know that feeling
before you go to a convention,
obviously not now, cause
you're miserable adults,
a few years earlier when
you're like kind of excited,
you're like bubbly, you're like,
"Oh my God, I'm so excited."
That's the feeling, like
fucking shoved it into a job
that I can just like, anytime I want.
(burping)
I can just take it.
(moaning)
- Snail's House to me is
like what it must sound like
to live in the Kirby universe.
- Yes, as well.
- That's,
that's what it sounds like to me.
- It's like fucking your enemies come up?
(burps)
- Yes.
- Everything is like, everything is like.
- Done.
- You can suck on everything.
- Done, over.
- Everything is like round
and like bubbly and pastel
colored and like overly happy.
But in a good way.
- I could fall over.
But the floors is made of mush, man.
- Yeah, exactly.
(all laughing)
- I dunno how to, that's
like in a good way.
Not unlike it's a kids way.
- No, no.
Not like a condescending way.
But like.
- I don't know
how to describe it.
- It's just like it's pillowy.
- Yeah, dude, it's great.
- Yeah, it's great.
- It's such a.
If you wanna be,
feel happy, and have a good time
and you wanna feel vibes,
trust Snail's House and
you don't want lyrics.
Cause I honestly, sometimes
lyrics get in the way.
Somehow these lyrics get away.
- Nah, no, I disagree.
- Sometimes, sometimes.
- Someone who doesn't
even listen to lyrics,
I feel something missing
without vocal track.
- Well, wait can talk about that.
- We can talk.
- I have other picks
that we can talk about by the way.
The other one I wanna talk about,
I love the Weeknd and this is a weird one
because I feel very long.
Very, very long time.
Just kind of felt indifferent
towards the Weeknd.
I felt like it was that artist
that just all always got like number ones,
but like, you know it was
kinda like (blabbers) whatever.
But then like the last album came out,
and I was like, "okay,
no, this is all fire."
This is all like really fucking good.
Okay, I think he's actually like insane.
And then I went back and
listened to the other stuff,
I appreciated it way more now,
- Yeah, yeah.
- After seeing how far he's grown
and how much his albums
have like just improved.
- No, I was definitely the same.
I was like, "Oh, this
is just like another,"
- The generic pop guy.
- Yeah, there's another.
- Bruno Mars X Figure.
- Exactly, exactly.
Cause like when I listened
to House of Balloons,
which was his first album, I was like,
"Ah, this is like, it's good.
"But it's like nothing special."
And then after Hours came out,
with like blended lights and I like it.
That album, I was like, "Okay,
okay I see it, I see it."
And then the new album was like,
"All right, solidified
it, you're pretty good."
- Dude, this album, it's
been like out for like,
I don't know, like two
months at this point.
And I've literally just
listened to that album nonstop.
It's so good, it's so good.
- I think The Weeknd actually
is right now the most
streamed artist on Spotify.
- It wouldn't surprise me.
- He's number one right now.
- This album has so
many bangers that like,
it's so fun talking this album to people
because everyone I've spoke to
has a different favorite song.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's not like other
albums where I'd say,
"Okay, everyone likes X song the most,
"and it's very predictable."
But it's like, everyone is just telling me
about other songs they like the most.
I'm like, "Oh yeah, that
one is a banger too."
- That's the best kind
of artist though, right?
Where it's like.
- Yeah.
- It's like, you can't pick like a top,
I would think it's really difficult
for someone like The Weeknd,
to make like a greatest hits album.
- Yeah, true.
- Because it's like,
which songs do we not
put in that album, right.
- True.
- Because every song's great.
- Also I love that like,
I wasn't paying attention to lyrics,
but then I started actually
paying attention to the lyrics,
this current album, I'm like,
"Man, this is really sad."
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- What's going on with this man?
He's like, "Yeah, I've gotta see a woman
"and she's fucking another man."
(laughing)
And then he's like,
"I'm so sad that she's
fucking another man."
And I'm just like, "What, what!"
He's like, "I loved her.
"And then she stepped on my heart."
And I'm like, "Whoa!"
- While in middies it's
like funk bass like plays
in the background.
- And then he's like,
"Get that harmer, get
over, it's so good though.
"It's so good, it's so good."
- Oh my God, I feel that it.
- He's like,
"I wanna marry her bush,
we're best friends now."
And he's like, "Oh no, oh no, oh no.
"What's going on, this is so sad."
- It's funny I love that.
- It's so fun, I love.
- How often do you listen to like mu,
lyrics in never in songs.
- Never, literally, never.
- So what made you listen
to the lyrics in this song,
in this album?
- And I listened to it
so many times, after a
point I started like,
just that he would say stuff
and I was like, "Hold on."
(laughing)
Like The Rock behind me.
- Rewind that back,
rewind that back.
- I listened to,
- Rewind that, rewind that.
- I was like, "Hold on, what, what?"
I'm like, "Jesus Christ man."
(laughing)
"Oh my God."
- And then.
- But we're like,
we're his therapist, you
know, we're just hearing it.
- Exactly.
- Bo Burnham?
You know, Bo Burnham
was one of those things
where you kind of have
to listen to the lyrics
to enjoy the music.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it really made me
see that like, "Okay."
Cause to me, comedy music before was like
just fucking Lonely Island.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like "Weird AI" Yankovic,
kinda thing, not really.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean it's,
it was like parody music.
- Yeah.
- Where they were kind of, for me,
it would like they would take a song
or an established genre of music
and just kind of like parody that.
On like a surface level,
if that makes sense?
- And Tim Minchin is obviously very,
everyone always loved him.
- Loved him, yeah.
- But like even there that music
I wasn't like super into it
But I don't know.
When I've watched my Bo Burnham
specials like all of them.
Like at least four plus times now,
and I just love it to death.
And I really like the
songs, they're really funny,
but also really good.
Some of them are like absolute bangers.
- Yeah.
- I love the one at the end of Make Happy.
You've got the one where it is,
but it's when he's talking
about Burritos had put the hand
in the Prickle Ken, I can't
remember it, so to say.
(chuckling)
What's the fucking term?
(Garnt laughing)
- That sounds
like something you'd really do.
- But it's so good though.
Cause it's like, it starts off as a joke
and then it turns into this whole,
the struggle of being a creative
and what people expect things from you
and how do you struggle with that,
And he's somebody who creates stuff.
I was like, "Oh shit,
whoa this is fucking.
"Whoa, this is weird."
- Yeah.
- Fuck it.
- Did you ever like get
into Lonely Island though,
back in then?
- I loved Lonely Island.
- Yeah, right.
- And I was,
when I was like 14, I
thought this shit was like
peak comedy and music.
(laughing)
I was like, "Oh my God, he
threw it on the ground."
Oh my dude,
that song is so good.
- Oh my God,
he put a dick in a box?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like, what the fuck!
- I'm like, "This song,
"is talking about three song."
- We're just advancing.
Damn, man.
- This song's about three songs?
(sarcastic laughing)
You know, cause I was a kid and
I thought she was hilarious.
Like I just had sex.
I thought that was like
the peak comedy, I think.
- Nah, for me it was like,
"I'm on a bar."
- I'm on a bar.
- I mean, just like heard T-Pain
in there, for no fucking reason.
I'm,
- It was that and Like a Boss.
- Yeah, Like a Boss.
- Also remember when those were like
the most viewed fucking videos on YouTube.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And they were like, I literally
remember cause I have this
weird memory of me playing Black Cops 1
and just playing Lonely
Island songs on repeat
while I'm playing and I
literally did nothing,
but listen to the Lonely Island.
- Okay, everyone was like that
in the early stages of YouTube though.
- But to me it was like Bo
Burnham is like it kind of took
the best of like comedy and
then added it with like amazing,
funny standup with
amazing lyrics and great,
and I love the song.
It's like one minute long.
It's the fucking Jeff
Bezos song from inside.
I fucking love that one.
- Yeah.
- You gotta listen to that.
- All right.
- It's so good.
- Cause I've only seen inside,
but obviously it is one of the few artists
where I did listen to their
songs, cause he is like.
I guess, I dunno how
you categorize or put,
how do you categorize these kind of songs?
But it's like comedy songs.
But it also like, his songs
also make you think, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like the message
kind of like sticks
with you for a while.
- It's funny and deep.
(laughs)
- Actually the best of all.
- Like the best of all.
- It's too, is it too deep for you?
I don't know.
But it's the Evan Gillion of comedy music.
(all laughing)
- Just shut the fuck up.
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- Yeah, know.
I wanted put it on, cause
I wanted to talk about it
and I thought that
it was really interesting
- Yeah, he's great.
- And you know, there's a lot of artists
I could have put on.
I could have put a, I love Pendulum.
- Pendulum is fantastic.
- I wanted to see Pendulum.
- I almost put Pendulum.
- I went to watch Pendulum live
and it was probably like their greatest
fucking experience ever.
- I'm sure, they're also good
- I nearly died like four times
being stepped on to death.
But it was amazing.
- That must,
that must have been like audio crack, man.
- Dude it was insane.
So I went to go and watch Pendulum
it was in a warehouse, like
this concrete warehouse.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it was just like,
some kind of Satanic ritual
that looked like.
Cause it was just, this thing was so tall.
So you just see this
massive hunk of concrete
and then just depends on
just going hard on scene.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Holy shit.
When I remember when Tarantula
came on, that was insane.
Everyone insane.
- Holy.
- It was just like,
I've never been in such a
like, just intense atmosphere.
It was so fun.
I don't normally like going to concerts,
but that almost really fun.
Cause I need the lyrics as well, somehow,
so I brought 'em into my memory.
Cause I listened.
- Are there that many lyrics
through Pendulum songs?
- Yeah.
- I can't remember.
- In some songs.
- I mean everyone.
- With Color, it's very easy.
- Everyone remembers the
opening to Witchcraft.
That's the one song everyone
would just start singing.
- She Ran, She Ran?
- Yeah.
I've been listening to the Pendulum
since I was like fucking 12
and I would listen them on and off.
- They were pretty inescapable back when.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Blood Sugar.
- Yeah.
- I remember the remix.
- Propane Nightmares as well.
- Sugar was, Prodigy of
what am I talking about
- It was like Pendulum and Prodigy.
- Prodigy that's it.
- Prodigy,
was that fucking massive.
- Yeah.
- I like, they were
inescapable at a point where,
like I remember, like they came out,
as like in the age where I
just started going clubbing
and like, you'd hear a Pendulum song
and a Prodigy song, at least
once in every fucking club
we goes, man.
- Pendulum is so good man,
so good.
But I said like Pendulum was
definitely my early inspiration
before I found I started
really getting into Daft Punk.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- Obviously Intastella, is amazing.
And all the music videos
just go so goddamn well
with the songs and I just,
- Not the movie, the album.
- Yeah, I understand that perfectly
- Not the soundtrack to the movie.
- Yeah, it's amazing.
- And then you got ANRI.
- Yeah, so this is just like city pop.
This is the, I can't
Stop The Loneliness song.
Have you heard that one?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I fucking love that song.
♪ I can't stop the loneliness. ♪
I dunno why I love that song.
- Oh man, we're gonna get
coffee, we're be right back.
You're too good.
- That's why
I'm singing it bad.
I'm singing it bad on purpose.
- You're too good.
- But I love, I love city pop.
Obviously, I dunno how to
encapsulate all of city pop.
I could just put plastic
love and call it day,
but, you know, I feel like
city pop has definitely
blown up in the past.
What, four or five years, it's gone crazy.
Even The Weeknd on his new album, Samples.
A lot of city pop.
- Oh yeah.
- And it's so Goddamn good.
It's like city pop with
the vocals for God.
It's just amazing, it's so good.
And I mean, I absolutely adore city pop.
It makes me nostalgic for that
time that I lived in Japan
in the '80s, Strait outta the Window.
- [Joey] Yeah, definitely.
- And was in the bubble period.
- [Joey] It was a good.
- It was a good time.
- Was it literally Plastic Love
that literally like kind of
reinvigorated this city pop trends
that's happening right now.
- I think so
cause used to hear city pop occasionally,
but I don't think anyone
- Yeah.
- The movement hadn't really taken off.
I think Plastic Love is
what really got people
into thinking abouts
listening to other songs.
cause I definitely heard city love,
city pop songs before this.
- Right.
- But never enough to make me
be like, "Is this a genre?"
I dunno what this is.
- and so, it was also
just like such a mystery
as to why it was that song that blew up.
I've seen like documentaries
on YouTube about like,
why did Plastic Love blow up and shit.
And it's like, because.
And I'm just like,
"Cause it's a good song."
- Yeah, I mean like,
- Nothing more.
- Also like the YouTube
algorithm just works
in fucking mysterious ways.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I mean, there's two ways
I get recommended song
that's memes or YouTube algorithm.
- Yes.
- Honestly memes is like
a really underrated way
to discover new music.
Cause a lot of memes.
- Bro, great pop,
it's so good.
- A lot of meme songs are
actually like good songs.
- Yeah.
- That you don't,
you'd forget that they're good songs
- That's true.
- Because you've just heard
it base boosted so many times.
- Baby I'm Yours is an ironically
like a fucking amazing song
and it's so fucking stupid
that I can't listen to the song,
without thinking of ladies
and gentlemen, we got it him.
And the fall like,
(blabbering) it's awful.
Ruin my life.
- No, cause I remember when I heard,
first heard that song,
- Shut up, man.
- It got recommended to me on
YouTube and I was just like,
"Oh it's the meme song."
And I was waiting for like
the base boost to come in
and then it just, it was just the song.
And I remember thinking,
"Damn, why did they bass boost
"this fucking masterpiece man?"
(Joey laughing)
It's like taking the Mona
Lisa and like spitting on it.
You know?
- Un-ironically
like crap dance song.
- Yeah, it's a good song.
- And the Shooting Star song.
Remember that one?
- Oh that was a good song.
Sounds good.
(shooting star beats)
- Oh yeah.
- You know that one.
That one was like good.
Actually.
- That's was good.
That's a great song.
They're great songs.
- Right, well that's my three by three.
Go and check some of them out,
- All right.
- You might like it.
If you like Daft Punk, you'll
probably like a lot of these.
- Others are Parcels.
- Yeah, you shouldn't try it.
I love Parcels, man.
Some of their songs are so fucking good.
This episode is sponsored
by Premium Bandai, USA.
Premium Bandi USA is one of
Bandai official online stores
that offers an extensive
ever-changing lineup
of high quality and limited run products
pulled right out of your
favorite anime series
Right now, as a part of
their special campaign,
they are offering free
shipping on all DiGi Mon
themed items until March 9th EST.
Today, Premium Bandai
has sent us a collection
of their newest DiGi Mon
items to show off to you.
- First of all, Garnt
is wearing it right now
a wearable Digivice.
- Ooh.
- Also known as the vital
bracelet digital monster
digivice V from the currently
airing DiGi Mon ghost game animate.
Not only does it monitor your heart rate
and count your steps,
but it all also levels up
your DiGi Mon accordingly
allow you to battle
other people's DiGi Mon.
It's like having a DiGi Mon on the go.
- That's such a cool concept.
(indistinct)
Honestly like having a fitness bracelet
that also levels up your
DiGi Mon as you work out.
Dude, weaves are finally
giving you working out.
- Double grinding.
Double grinding.
(laughing)
- [Garnt] They've also sent
us a set of card sleeves
with matching Playmat to give you
an idea of what two of their
new DiGi Mon card game items
currently alpha pre-order look like IRL
- Wow.
- [Garnt] Check out each of their designs
on screen right now.
- I love DiGi Mon, gotta say
it's a nice size playmat.
- It is.
- And have plenty of playing.
- [Garnt] It is.
- Check out all the items
displayed on our table today
and much more, on Premium Bandai USA
during their free shipping campaign.
By clicking the link in
the new description below.
Thanks again, at Premium Bandai
USA for sponsoring us today.
Back to the episode.
- All right, well that's my
initial Trash Tasting in music.
Thank God that's outta way.
- Initial Trash Taste.
- And before we move on,
obviously you talked
about a lot of your music
that you're into now, but like what?
I'm curious were you listen to as a kid?
Do you remember, or did you just not want
any of them on.
- Plague, plague.
- Like, as all as you can remember.
- Yeah, I like Foo Fighters.
That was a big one, Biffy
Clyro, Pendulum, Prodigy.
Then I had that weird
phase where I was like,
"Yeah, Calvin Harris is really good."
(chuckling)
- I was actually like this close
with Calvin Harrison.
- No (indistinct)
- Just to be like,
- Well, did I end racism.
He did end racism.
- I would have.
Yeah, he did.
- Yeah.
- I would be like, if I
didn't go through a phase
where I listened to a
fucked ton of Calvin Harris.
- Listen, I'm not immune
to shit taste, right?
There was a point where
I listened to a lot,
a lot of Calvin Harris.
- Did you listen to a lot
of David Guetta as well?
- Oh, my God, sure I did.
You know when you listen to that
- Swedish House Mafia?
- The Aeroplanes
in the night sky song?
- Yeah.
- You're like, how about
I, I just want all music
that sounds exactly like this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like IPS, you know.
(laughing)
- When I have like no, no
fucking personality of my own,
I would just listen to
what the charts told me
was good music.
- Well, the Billboard was like
the Billboard top 100.
- It's top 20.
I wanna, I wanna fit in.
I wanna see normal, I'm
gonna say I like this song.
I love that new Calvin Harry song.
I felt like I almost like
listening to that music
just so I could have,
I could keep up with what
people were talking about,
- You keep up with, yeah.
- Cause I didn't wanna get
bullied for like, you're
like Scottish bands
that no one talked about.
- No,
what the fuck's wrong with that?
- Well, you know,
it's back when,
- A lot liked it.
- Was a lot of social pressure.
- Yeah.
Like me listening to Calvin
Harris was the equivalent
of me watching football matches.
So I could have something to talk about.
It was like, "Oh yeah, you see a,"
- That's true.
- Yeah, you see a latest football match?
"Oh yeah."
- Yeah.
- The you hear Calvin
Harrison song came out.
That was pretty good, wasn't it?
- But I feel like I never
really had defined music taste
cause I was kind of, you know.
Well, back then I had to find
a means to get ahold of it.
- Yeah.
- And that often was a big limiting factor
on what I could discover.
- I did the opposite.
I was like,
"Oh I listened to that
recent Calvin Harris song,
"but its shit innit."
(all laughing)
- I've never had.
- It's bullshit.
- Well, you have good taste show.
You,
- Shit tasting music.
Shit taste.
- You have good taste as well.
- When I didn't even like to think that.
I was like, I didn't even listen to it.
All right, I'm just
giving you a hard time.
(both laughing)
- All right, we should we
get on with the next pick.
- All right.
- Do you wanna pick it or should I pick?
- You can go for it, man.
Meal gone, it doesn't really matter.
- Matters too me.
(Joey laughing)
It's not gonna matter.
- I see a T.
- Oh, it's me.
- Thank God, you're saved, I guess.
- Okay, thank you.
Thank God, Joey can carry the podcast
after I finished talking about that.
- My pleasure.
- Okay.
So how I tried to pick
this, I tried to pick this.
I tried to pick music, and artist,
and songs that really defines
every stage of my life.
So this might be a little bit random.
- We're gonna see pepper
take the full album.
What do you mean diaper music?
Like, let's see, witty spider?
- Bob the Builder soundtrack.
- It was a cold summer night.
Yeah, the age of three.
I decided it was on a summer.
- You know, twinkle, twinkle, little star.
Fucking banger.
- Thomas the Tank.
- What can I fucking say?
- Has an absolute banger soundtrack.
There's no like.
- Bob the Builder
that opening was like.
(Connor laughing)
- Postman Pat.
- Bob the Builder still slap.
- Postman Pat, I fucking love that song.
- All right, Ashley, put
it up, Ashley, put it up.
Go on.
- This motherfucker will
not leave my record.
(Joey, Garnt laughing, clapping)
- Yes, yes.
- Okay.
So I guess, I'll go through it from right,
from left to right, sorry.
- [Connor] I wonder all of these.
- [Garnt] You know, all these?
- I don't know the one.
- I do get.
- [Joey] I don't know this one.
- You don't know that one?
That's the, that's one of the two Japanese
ones from their charts.
I know three Japanese ones.
- Yeah, it's true.
- So top left is Muse.
- [Connor] Really?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
We got we got Muse.
- You know what I'm saying?
- [Garnt] We got Muse
and then we have Bradio
and then we have The Kooks or is it?
No, it's just Kooks, right?
- [Joey] Kooks, yeah.
- [Garnt] We have The Killers.
We have Michael Jackson.
- [Joey] MJ.
- [Garnt] We have MJ, come on.
We have Zutomayo.
We have Daft Punk, Arctic Monkeys
and obviously the Fooly Cooly Sound.
- I dunno why I thought
those Ben's still off,
I'm just saying.
(Garnt laughing)
- Oh, Ben still does not,
does not like that bag.
(both laughing)
- I was like, "Damn Ben still got the."
All right.
- All right.
So, where do you want to start off?
- Dude, who Kooks?
I like 'em that much.
- Okay, so the reason I
put The Kooks there, right?
Or Kooks I can't.
Is it the Kooks or is it just kooks?
- It doesn't matter.
- I'm obviously a fan.
- [Cameraman] Is that Kooks?
- Is it the Kooks?
- I thought it was the Kooks.
- That's what I thought.
This is specifically inside
in, the inside out the album.
Cause it's one of the
few albums I actually
have listened to all of the way.
(laughing)
And the reason I put the Kooks in there,
is because they are originally
a band from Brighton, right?
- We gotta represent our home country.
- No, no, no, exactly.
But its like, I did not know this.
I did not know this for the longest time.
But listening to their music
and listening to this album, especially.
Before I found out they
were from Brighton,
I was just like fuck,
this literally epitomizes
the Brighton vibe.
Unlike what it is like being a teenager
growing up in Brighton.
It literally epitomizes
the vibe of going to
like this random fucking beach party,
or just going to a random house
party in England sometimes.
- That privileged lifestyle.
trying to pick up chicks or just you know,
just heavily binge drinking or whatever.
- Right, right.
- Like if I had to pick
a show, for example,
a TV show that epitomized,
British teenage life,
it is The Inbetweeners.
If you've seen The Inbetweeners,
I've not seen a more
accurate representation
of what it is to be like growing up,
growing up at around like college age,
which college age is kinda
like high school age, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And to me, The Kooks is,
if you listen to this album,
it is growing up in Brighton college age.
So about 16 to about 16 to 18 years old.
And that's why it's on there.
- I feel like I only know one song.
- I think there were like
two big songs on there.
There's like Naive.
And like.
- Yeah, Naive.
Say naive.
(both laughing)
It's really like,
- Perfect accent.
- I'm just like really drawn out.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like every, every word, I think.
- And I think just like
She Moves in Her Own Way.
That's the other side.
- Oh, I know that song.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
♪ Oh, oh. ♪
(all laughing)
- That one, that one is
like burned into my head.
- It is because.
- It all the time in the UK.
- That was the song that like
introduced me to the Kooks.
But I feel like those are
the two most, like Naive
and She Moves in Her Own Way, I was like,
I like the two most poppy
songs in their album
because definitely their
later albums, they got like,
they like way got way, like way
on the poppy side of things.
They were kind of like,
kinda like a Maroon 5 in that sense.
You compare early Maroon 5 albums
to the later Maroon 5 albums.
And it's just like,
"Okay, this is,"
- like night and day.
- Yeah, this is night and day.
This is like, okay.
There was a point where I like Maroon 5
and then there's just like
billboard 100 Maroon 5.
You know?
- You know like,
- Does she moves like Jacamo.
- You don't like.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, you're right.
- You don't like sugar?
(laughs)
- No.
- You don't like sugar?
They're going soon.
- No.
- I love sugar.
- But I will stick off
for like early Maroon 5.
I think early Maroon 5 was
actually pretty damn good.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I don't really know
what else to say about the Kooks.
That's why the Kooks is on there.
If you want to have a.
- It's a good band, eh?
- Yeah, it's a good band,
it's a good Indie band.
So a lot of these, a lot of these,
a lot of bands I wanted
to put on were of course,
Indie bands, especially a lot
of Indie bands from England,
I guess, because I did, I did go through,
I think the period of life,
my life, where I went,
where I listened to the
most music is probably
in between high school and university
where I listened to a lot
of fucking Indie bands.
And a lot of that was
because I was actually
in a band myself.
I don't, I dunno if I've,
- Were you?
- Yeah, I dunno if I've
ever talked about this.
- No, you've never talked about this.
- We've never talked about this.
- Have I ever, never mentioned
this to you guys?
- Never mentioned it.
What did you play.
- What did you play?
- I play guitar.
- What?
- Are you serious.
- I'm serious, I'm serious.
- I didn't know this.
Can you still play guitar?
- Why have we not started a band?
- I don't.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Do you know how long
I've been waiting.
- Me on vocals?
- Yeah.
- Joey on.
- No, Connor on vocals,
obviously.
- Yeah.
- Garnt on guitar
And I'll just fill the rest.
- Whatever, Joey's the prince.
You can do everything else.
(Joey laughing)
- Have I never mentioned this before?
- No.
- Never, never mentioned this.
- I must have.
- You've mentioned that
you used to play guitar like a little bit.
- This feels like, so
you should mention more.
- Yeah.
- This feels like a personality trick.
- I feel betrayed that you
haven't mentioned this.
- I guess like, okay.
I guess I'll go again.
Tell again to this story then.
Okay, let's start right at the beginning.
- Next, you gonna say that you
were a member of the Kooks.
(all laughing)
- But yeah, I was one of them.
- Absolutely Garnt was a
platinum selling artist.
- So I guess the reason
I just wanted to learn
how to play guitar in the first place,
is my first choice on that, it's Muse.
- I love the Muse.
- I remember the first time
hearing Plug in Baby, and
just hearing that riff.
- Ugh.
- And like just something.
- God like.
- Something just clicked in my mind.
And I was just like, "I need
to be able to play this."
(Connor laughing)
I need to be able to play this.
And like I remember before,
my mom had always tried
to get me to learn guitar,
cause she's just like,
I really like people playing guitar.
Oh cool.
You know, my mom thinks this is cool
when I'm just like, she set
me for like guitar lessons
as a kid and I never
really took them seriously.
I was just like, "I'm doing
this cause my mom wants me
"to do it."
I can play fucking Oasis, Wonderwall,
whatever the fuck,
- Which I would argue is the
only song you need to know.
- Yeah, yeah, the only
song you need to know.
Okay, I was just like, "Whatever."
And we only own a acoustic
guitar at the time.
And the I went, I remember I
went into secondary school,
which is like just, I guess
just before high school age,
in the UK or is it high school age?
I dunno, secondary school.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I remember the first
time hearing Plug in Baby.
And I was just like,
"Why did they never teach us
"how to play this in guitar lessons?
"What the fuck!"
I know how to play a
barcode, a bar chords, sorry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- what do I need to do to
learn how to play this?
And so the first thing I did was I,
- Ditch your acoustic.
- Yeah, I ditched my acoustic.
I signed up for guitar lessons,
in my secondary school.
And I was like,
"Mother, I would like
an electric guitar now."
(both laughing)
- Did she get you one?
- Huh?
- I remember we got a fucking
cheap ass electric guitar
from like,
- Amazon basics.
- No, not even Amazon basics.
I got one lap that was
on like a carbon sale
or something like that.
- Thought of that.
- Which was.
- Which is a trick.
- Yeah, yeah.
That did a trick.
So I can't even remember
what my first guitar was.
It was a shit guitar.
It was one where I had to like replace
all of the fucking strings on the guitar.
Cause all of the strings
were like rusted already.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
- Like at that point, I didn't even know
how to like properly tune or
change the strings of a guitar.
So my teacher at the time
had to teach me how to do it.
I mean that's when I like,
that's when I like first
properly got into learning
how to play the guitar,
and at that point, as the
point where I was building up
my skill level to you know,
be able to play Plug in Baby,
which eventually I did.
- Hell, yeah.
- And then, actually now
that I think about it,
once I learn how to play Plug in Baby,
that my drive to improve my skill level,
just kinda just stopped.
- I have reached peak top.
- I'm like you know when you,
- There's never a need
to play it again.
- You know, when I like,
you know when you've reached
the goal you set for yourself
and I just never found a
next goal, to set for myself.
So for me, it was just like play guitar,
to play Plug in Baby, I can do it now.
Mother, I can stop playing the guitar now.
- Oh my God.
- Disposing of this.
- I was one of the play guitar hero
more than one of the play guitar.
[Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- And then, so then in that
time, one of my friends,
he wanted to start a band and I was like,
"Why not?
"I've got nothing bad to do at this time.
You know, I can play the guitar.
"I might as well use it for some,"
- First first day lessons.
Do you know, Plug in Baby?
- Tickle, tickle little star,
- We can play that.
- And so, yeah.
I mean, I joined because
I wasn't doing really,
doing anything with the guitar
aside from trying to learn
how to play Plug in Baby.
So I'm just like, "Maybe
I'll just join the guitar,
"maybe I'll just join a band for fun."
- Yeah.
- I mean, I don't think
we were the greatest band,
but you know, 'em after me.
- Did you ever play?
- Yeah, yeah.
We played like a bunch of gigs.
Actually I got like,
- What?
- Yeah, yeah.
I've like, I think the
biggest crowd we played in
was kind of like 500 to a thousand people.
- What!
- What?
- Okay.
- Oh my God.
- How have you never told the story?
- Okay, so I remember when we were tryna
think of a band name.
I think we have like a
fucking stupid band name.
Okay.
- They're always stupid,
trust me.
- Our band name.
We're like try to brainstorm
a bunch of fucking band names
and nothing just seemed
to click because nothing,
everything sounded either like too metal
or too campy or whatever.
- Right, right.
- And then we just went on,
we just went with the name,
Nine and A Half Pounds.
(Joey laughing)
Because the month before my mate,
one of the lead singer went on a diet
and he lost nine and a half pounds,
and that was like, we were
just like, "You know what?
"We don't know what we're
gonna call our band.
"Let's just use this as just the name
"until we think of the
actual name for the band."
And then that just,
and then that was just like,
- That's a amazing.
- As with a lot of names
- Yeah, it just sticks, right?
- You pick a fill name
and you just like,
"Can't be us a stranger now."
- So you would just like play any song?
What kind of songs did you play?
- So I mean.
- Muse.
- Oh, just Muse?
- No, I mean, we wrote our own songs.
- Oh.
- So we'd go.
So my mate had, we went
to the drummer's house
because our drummer,
- You always gather at
the drummer's house,
the drummer's house.
Cause you can bring your fucking guitar,
you can bring your bass or
whatever to someone's house.
You can't transport a drum kit everywhere.
You know what I mean?
So at first we went to the
drummer's house to practice
and then, and write songs.
And eventually we had this really
like fucking old music studio
that friend of a friend
of a friend's dad owned,
you know that kinda thing?
- That's pretty cool.
- And you walk in, it's like a back alley
and like the fucking door hinges,
like when broken in 10
million times or something.
And you're like, "I
might get stabbed here,
"but they have a drum kit
and a recording studio here."
- Right, right.
- It's so cool.
- So whatever, let's just,
- That's amazing.
- And I remember the
biggest gig we played,
was like, we signed up to,
what was the equivalent
of a battle of the bands kind of deal?
- What the fuck.
Bro, you had Anatomy Arc?
- Yeah.
- So like,
- This is just a Beck.
(both laughing)
- No, no, part of the reason
why I got so into Beck
and why Beck was one
of my favorite.
- How the fuck,
didn't you say this when
you were talking about band?
- Yeah.
- I think I did mention it.
- You did not.
- You didn't.
- I must have mentioned this.
- No.
- You didn't not.
I would remember if you were like,
"By the way I was in a battle
of bands and performed,"
- I think I would remember the
name, nine and a half pounds.
- Okay, so we were just a band for fun.
We weren't taking this seriously.
- Of course.
- But we met like a lot of bands
who were fucking amazing
that came out of our school.
Cause I guess part of the other
reason why we formed a band
was because we are, the school I went to
was a performing art school.
So a lot of people there were doing,
were doing performing arts,
whether it was theater
or music or something.
So there were some people in my school,
and like my classmates,
who were taking music,
really, really seriously.
We were just like, "Whatever,
I'm learning guitar.
"I'll just play in,
"I'll just play in the band
"because whatever, that
seems like a cool way
"to spend my time."
And so I remember for
this Battle of The Bands,
we literally had to do audition
to get into this battle of bands, right.
And it was a pretty big deal at the time
because this gig was pretty famous
for like a lot of students.
And there was like, there was,
sometimes there would even
be people from music labels
who would attend events like this.
- That's cool, though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So we weren't expecting
anything to come out of this.
We were just like, "You know what?
"they're holding auditions at our school
"and we could sign up."
So we're just like, "What
have we got to lose?"
We didn't really.
- Yeah, why not?
- We didn't really expect anything
because we didn't really think
that we were that good of band.
So we obviously auditioned
and it was literally like
the fucking X Factor kind
of thing, kinda deal, right.
Because.
- The big golden
buzzer in the middle.
- Yeah, because literally we'd,
because our school was a performing arts,
so we had like a theater set up, right.
And the theater, we had like
a drum kit in the middle
and we had, there were judges on there.
- Oh wow.
- And we had to, we had to play two songs.
We had to play two songs
in front of the judges.
And I remember,
- That's where Garnt
plays Plug in Baby.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And the crowd goes wild.
Sorry, sorry.
- Now for our second song,
Plug in Baby.
One more time, baby.
- It's where the montage starts,
everyone gets up on there.
Okay, they're gonna tell you.
- And then I remember we were like,
we were hearing some of our fucking,
some of the other bands
that were playing before us.
And we were just like, "Fuck my life.
"We gotta follow these guys.
"We go fuck, we go fuck.
What the fuck?"
And so I remember thinking,
"we're not gonna get on."
Because there were a lot of other bands
that were fucking better than us.
I'm gonna say that.
But so we went on, we
just played our songs.
The judges you know,
waved us off, whatever.
We didn't expect much.
And so we didn't get into
the Battle of the Bands.
We actually became like a backup choice.
Just in case, just in case, you know?
- All right.
- Right, right.
- And so we went on with our lives
and then we get a call, like
a week before the events.
- You're in.
- And they were just like,
"So one of the bands is dropped out
"and we got an extra space in this
"Battle of the Band's concerts.
"Do you wanna do you wanna come on?"
And we're like, "what the fuck!"
- This is literally Carole & Tuesday.
Like that's exactly what
happened in Carole & Tuesday.
- This is an animate, bro.
- And so we were just like,
I mean, yes, but how the fuck
can we prepare in a week?
For this Battle of the Bands,
which is like other
bands have prepared for,
for like a good month or two.
Playing with a band is
fucking much more difficult
than you imagined it.
If you've never played in band before,
because you're in a live setting, right?
And a lot of things can go wrong
and you need to be on the same wavelength
as your other band members.
We've had, I've played plenty of gigs
and some gigs are better than others.
Sometimes you make
mistakes, and sometimes,
you're not in sync with
the rest of the band
and you need to be tight.
You need like the performance
needs to be tight.
So you need a lot of practice.
So we said yes, but we didn't really,
we didn't really have
time to practice the songs
that we wanted to of practice.
- Right.
- But there was like,
well, there was like one joke
song that we had practiced,
we had practiced before,
because we didn't really
have any gigs coming up.
And it was.
- I just had sex by Lonely Island.
- No, no, it was an Indie rock version
of Hit Me Baby One More
Time by Britney Spear.
- Oh, that's fucking awesome.
- It was Hit Me Baby One
More Time by Britney Spears.
- Hell yeah.
- And we were just like,
"Well, we don't really
have time to practice
"some of our more complicated songs.
"So let's just put that in the set,
"whatever right, whatever right."
And I remember we had the
conversation before of,
we always wanted the experience
of having the audience,
having audience, seeing part of the song,
like a lot of bands do.
- Yeah, of course.
- And I remember we were
having this discussion
of the perfect point
of this song would be,
what's the line.
How does Hit Me Baby
One More Time, go again?
- [Camera Man] ♪ Baby,
hit me one more time ♪
- I think he's thinking
about the chorus, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
Oh fuck.
- Hit me baby one more time.
- No, no, I go again.
No, no, no, here it is.
It's when the line goes is my loneliness
is killing me.
- Is killing me and yeah.
- And I.
And we were saying that
would be an awesome point
for like the audience to chime in.
But we were just to do,
do the, and to, to do the and diet.
Cause that would be that,
that would be like an
awesome feeling we thought.
- Yeah, of course.
- But we were just like,
"no, we're not gonna do it."
Because like, what's more embarrassing
than stop because then stopping a song,
letting the audience sing and,
- And no one sings.
- And no one sings,
we did not have the fucking balls
to do this, right.
- I've been there.
- And so I remember we go to
the Battle of the Bands
and it's like the biggest audience so far.
Normally we're used to performing
for like 50 to a hundred people.
So this was like,
- Which is still a lot.
- Which is still a lot,
you know, which is a lot.
But this was like about 500 people.
It was at like Concorde
2, which if you know,
and if you know Brighton,
Concorde 2 is actually
one of the biggest venues.
That's not like the Brighton,
that's not the main Brighton venue.
It's a lot of big Indie bands go there.
- That's cool.
- And so we go on stage
and we're just like,
"Guys, we're not gonna
take them seriously.
"A lot of these bands are fucking amazing.
"We're just gonna have fun.
"We're just."
- Which is so anime.
- Yeah.
- "We're just,
"we're just going to have fun, right?"
And I remember, so we go on stage,
we play the set and this is
me playing on pure adrenaline.
So we're not practiced at all.
We're not as tight as we want to be
in terms of our performance.
But I'm seeing like, for some reason,
just playing in front
of the biggest crowd,
kinda like hyped us up.
And I can't really explain the feeling,
but it just like something
that day just clicked.
You know some days where
you're just like in the zone?
That day, for some reason, all
of us were just in the zone.
We were like at peak performance, right?
- Yeah.
- And then I remember we decided
because we were of meme it up,
we were decided we were
going to end it on,
Hit Me Baby One More Time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The rest of it was just
going to be our original songs
and we were gonna end it on that,
because we were just like,
"we don't care, whatever."
The audience is probably
not gonna like it,
cause it's fucking Britney Spears,
but we're just gonna have fun with it.
And then I remember when
we start playing the song,
somehow the audience
just like erupts, right.
The cause this is not the type of audience
that would listen to
fucking Britney Spears.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're here for like Arctic Monkeys,
they're here for Block Party or you know,
The Clarks or some shit like that.
And I remember playing this song.
And obviously, we had
agreed that we weren't
going to stop the music
with The Anri, right?
But you saw, we saw
the energy in the crap.
(Joey laughing)
- You had no choice.
- And we were like, it was such a,
it was one of the most
surreal moments in my life.
Where we had this,
we had this performance where
we were just all like in this.
We were in flow, you know?
- Yeah.
- We were just in, we were like
Karaoke basket in the zone.
I remember the moment was coming up.
And I looked over,
I looked over at the drummer.
- Over the drummer.
That's so adamant.
We all look at him.
- We all at the drummer.
- No, no, no, cause I remember,
I was like, "I want do this."
But we agreed that we wouldn't.
And I remember, I remember thinking
I wanna do this.
- Do it.
- And I remember looking at the drummer
and he had like the same look, as I did.
(laughing, clapping)
I looked over the bases
and the bases just like,
- Oh my God.
- And then, he nodded at me.
And then, I looked over to the
singer and in the corner of,
he sees me, on the corner of my eye,
at the corner of his eye.
And I'm just like,
(Joey laughing)
And then he nods back and I'm just like,
"Okay, it's going to happen."
And so he goes,
♪ My loneliness is killing me ♪
Silence.
♪ And I ♪
And like the fucking entire
concert hall, just like fucking.
They complete the line.
And it's just like.
(Connor laughing)
I can't explain, that fucking feeling.
It is.
- It's better than sex.
- It is like the biggest orgasm,
(Joey laughing)
I've had in my life, like.
- For Sydney.
(all laughing)
- Cause it was, I dunno.
It was kinda like a Disney moment for me.
Cause like somehow everything
just fucking came together
and then we just, we
could continued the song
and it was the best,
like the best reaction
that we've ever got from a crowd.
- Wow.
- So the Battle of the
Bands was done by votes
and there were 10 bands there.
We came in third.
- Oh wow.
- Oh shit.
- Did you get anything, any prize?
- No, we didn't get any prize.
- Oh fuck.
- We didn't get any prize.
But that would.
- They did get the biggest
orgasm of his life.
- That, that was the peak of my.
- Music career.
- That was the peak of my music career.
It all went down from that.
- I mean,
that's pretty ridiculous considering this.
What?
How many hundreds of bands
that have probably never experienced that.
- True.
And from that down onward,
he relinquished the name Garnt.
(both laughing)
He became gone.
He wasn't right to use the name really.
- Like Leveled Up and Evolved.
- Yeah, they can't use the name anymore.
That must be crazy.
How the fuck have you
never brought this up?
- How did you never brought this up?
- I don't know, I just.
I swear, I've said, "I've
been in a band before."
And no one's ever just.
- Everyone's been in a band before.
No, everyone's been in a band before.
- Oh, yeah.
- I've been in a band for like 10 seconds
until I realize it's horrible idea.
(both laughing)
- Yeah, I dunno that.
I mean, that's why I've
really liked Beck because I'm,
I looked up Beck and I'm
just like, "Fuck, I get that.
"I get that."
- That's my life.
- So you were actually good at guitar?
- I was like competent at guitar.
- Oh, you've played in front of people.
That's pretty good.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
I've played in front of people, but.
- I mean that's, I've in my
mind, but that's pretty good.
- So we're starting a band
called 10 and a half pounds soon.
(Garnt laughing)
- 10 And a half.
- I look forward to you guys.
- You like unlocked memories in me.
I heard the Zelda (blabbers)
thing when you were like,
I remember I tried to learn guitar.
What I tried?
- All right.
- I think my parents nudged me towards it.
- Right.
I just remember being
in someone's house playing guitar,
trying to do twinkle, twinkle little star.
- Right.
- I just was like,
- I dunno.
(laughs)
I was like, "I don't get this."
And then he was like, gave me
this device that was a tuner,
but I didn't know what it did.
He was like, "You gotta do
it, until it goes green,
"the light."
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, "why?"
(both laugh)
"It all sounds the same.
"It all sounds very similar."
- It's just one beep to one,
- And my parents bought this tuna for me.
And I remember just,
even at that time when
I was eight, I was like,
Why my parents just wasted
their money on this tuna?
(laughs)
I'm never gonna get good at this.
I'm never gonna good at this.
(both laughing)
So I'd never, never learned guitar.
And then I remember I went to learn drums,
which seems pretty fitting
for me cause I'm, you know?
- Oh, you just need a
sense of rhythm, that's it.
And hand eye coordination.
- Which is great.
I've had great hand, eye coordination.
Unfortunately, no rhythm.
So that was the crux of that one.
And that was over with it, and
I never really learned drums.
I went for like a year and I
never really learned anything.
- Really?
- They try to meet,
they try to teach me how
to read the Sheet music.
- Ah.
- Oh, yeah.
- And that's where I was like,
"No, I don't wanna do this."
- That's like jazz drumming methods.
- Yeah, I didn't enjoy it.
- I think,
I stopped learning at the point
when cheap music started to
become a thing of my lessons.
- Right.
- I'm just like,
"I don't like this anymore."
(both laughing)
- This used to be fun
when we were just talking
about beeps and boobs, now
you brought reading into this.
That's what I draw the line.
- Yeah, because like I, I
think we said this last time
where I go by feeling
and that's what I went
when I wrote the songs.
- Animate Protagonist
that you ever said.
- Cause I don't understand
a single thing about fucking music theory.
I know which chords sound nice in my head.
And sometimes I have like a nice,
like beat or rhythm in my head.
And I'm just like,
"Let's try to play this out with guitar."
I do not wanna know
what fucking music theory is.
- You're literally
Yuri from K-ON, like a 100%.
Like in the way you think
is 100%, it's exact same.
I was like, "I can't read shit.
"I just feel, and I complain."
- I remember at one
point, for some reason,
one of my friends was like,
"Yeah, we need to sing."
I was like, "Ah, alright, I'll do it.
"I'll do it."
- Really?
- "I'll do it."
Yeah, I couldn't sing at all.
- Right.
- I didn't have any confidence in it.
The first song, I'm not even kidding.
The first song that we had to learn,
is the only one I ever bothered learning.
- Yeah.
- We never did anything.
This died by this song.
Guess what song we had to sing.
- Muse song?
- No, it was fucking Smash Mouth.
(laughing, clapping)
I remember like actually,
- why did you not pursue it?
- I have like very vivid memories
of me actually, seriously
trying to learn how to sing
fucking All Star before it was a meme.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- And I remember when
this became a huge meme,
I was like, "this is like
I had Nam flashbacks,
Oh my God, oh my God.
This is the song.
- I need to hear it.
- Nam.
- An actual serious cover of Smash Mouths.
All star.
- We go to karaoke.
- Yeah, we,
- Because every time you go,
every time we go to karaoke,
of course, All Star comes up.
Like at least four or five
times throughout the night.
And every time, it's just kind
singing like a dumb voice.
I want you to actually like be serious,
and like try and like view.
- If I seriously try and sing.
- Yeah.
- I feel vulnerable.
- What?
- I feel open criticism.
I can't do that.
- No it's, no, no, I won't.
- If I'm the clown it's safe.
- No, no, no.
- Safety.
- Come on.
- I get that Connor,
I get that.
- I'm at something.
- No, you can't hide.
You can't hide.
- I'll hide behind my.
- Now that you've said that.
- I'll hide,
behind my clown makeup,
thank you very much.
- Now, that you said
that you have to do that.
- So what's your first pick?
(Connor laughing)
- That was my first pick, Muse.
- Oh my God, it's been like four hours.
- It is, yeah.
So I mean Muse is one of the only bands
I've also seen live as well.
- I didn't know Bradio,
had such amazing hair look at that.
- Yeah,
Bradio's got the best shit.
- Holy shit.
- Michael Jackson's running for his money
on that fucking Afro.
- Honestly.
This is like the early
days of Bradio as well.
Bradio like his Afro,
like now is fucking massive.
- It's huge, yeah.
- He looks like dinosaur.
- It's huge.
I mean, I've also seen
Bradio alive as well.
I mean the reason I put
Bradio you up there,
it's because I discovered
Bradio with Sydney
during a really tough and time trying time
in our lives, when like,
I was living in London,
working for the BBC.
And every day like was like
depressing a shit of course.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, especially with
the computer that I had.
- [Connor] Right, right.
- But for some reason, for some reason,
no matter how down my day was,
I put on a Bradio song,
and I am instantly happy.
For just like the five minutes
or three minutes, whatever.
I could just feel glad
and happy for a second.
- Is it bad?
I can't remember which songs they've done,
which animates they've done?
- They did Death Parade OP.
- That's it.
- They like,
- That's the like I thought it was that.
I didn't wanna say,
cause I didn't wanna look
as an ass-hole.
♪ Everybody ♪
♪ Put your hands. ♪
- That song does hard.
- Yeah, I mean like,
- Goes so hard.
- It was not only that song,
but I remember what really
sold me on Bradio was,
first time I heard that song,
of course it was a banger.
Everyone heard the Death Parade OP opening
and they knew it was a banger,
but it was actually
their music video, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Cause if you see their music video,
it's just like four dudes having
fun with the green screen.
And it's like got such this,
it's got such a charm to it.
Because they do a, they do this a lot
with some of their music videos
where they're just taking a person like,
trying to like either
replicate this anime opening
because what they did in this music video
was they've tried to
replicate the anime opening
of death parades, just with a green screen
and four of them and
it was just using like,
very basic cosplay and a green screen
and makeup and all this stuff.
And it's just, it's got
such a charm to them
because it just shows
that, it just feels like
it's four dudes having
fun, having a fucking blast
and not really giving a shit
about what the world thinks
about them, you know.
- My other favorite music
video by them is a Golden Liar.
- Oh, Golden Liar.
- Where they're just like,
it's literally just like them on stage.
- Yeah, yeah.
And they're just having
the time of their life.
And it's such a good song and
it's such a good music video,
it's so fun.
- Such a good baseline as well.
- Oh.
- Guys,
like the funk in that baseline.
Whoa.
- So good, so fucking good.
- Actually,
I wanna listen to them?
- Yeah.
- You should.
I feel like you like
them, because they're.
- Honestly, like the
rest of their discoveries
is like nothing will be bangers.
- Fuck, yeah.
- I haven't heard
a bad Bradio song.
- Yeah, before we move
on from Muse though,
I have a funny story or not a funny story
because I remember when I saw them live,
it was in Thailand.
- In Chelsea.
- And like I, I.
- They went to Thailand?
- No, that's the thing, right?
It was when I was living in Thailand.
- Right.
- And it was so fucking random.
Cause I'd gone my entire life,
being a massive Muse
fan living in England.
No, and just never getting
the chance to fucking see them
at all because they never
performed when I was in England.
And so, the first time in my life
that I actually got to see them perform,
was it in Bangkok, Thailand?
Like what the fuck?
- Probably good.
- So I remember like, I
remember thinking this,
is this this real?
This is so surreal that
I'm going to be able
to see Muse in Thailand, out
of all the places in the world,
I could see Muse.
So I remember going to this concert
where dragging Sydney
along, because of course,
even though she wasn't as
big of a Muse fan as I was.
So I needed something to go with me.
And so I remember like,
this was like the highlight of my month,
Cause I'm like, "Fuck me, man.
"I get to see Muse.
"I get to fucking see Muse."
And I remember, I remember
going to the concert
and I remember going to the stage
and just like eagerly
excited for them to come on.
And I remember the
first band that came on,
was a band called The Ruse.
The Ruse.
- Okay.
- Okay, so that's R-U-S-E,
right?
- Right.
- So I forgot that they needed
a supporting band, right?
So my first thought was,
have we just gone to the
wrong fucking concert?
Is this some Muse concert?
- Or is this a Ruse concert?
- Like what?
Is this the tie knockoff of the Muse?
What's going on?
And then they start playing and I'm like,
"Okay, maybe they're just
gonna play one song."
And then they play the second song.
I'm like, "okay, maybe
they're gonna play two songs,
"and then Muse is gonna come on."
They play five songs.
(all laughing)
- Oh, no.
- And after the fourth song,
I'm just like, "have I
made a terrible mistake?"
"And we've just come to Bangkok,
Thailand, to see the Ruse."
- Oh no, no.
(Joey laughing, clapping)
- Did they end up coming or?
- But they did,
I kind of thank God.
- OK, thank God.
- But I was just like, I
just remember thinking,
at first I was like, "You know,
maybe it's a sporting band"
and then like four songs later.
I really hope, I didn't
just spend all this money
to see a ducking knock
off Muse, band, man.
- You're juiced by The Ruse.
- Did they do that on purpose?
They had The Ruse, supporting The Muse?
- Maybe, maybe.
- Impossibly.
- They must have done that on purpose.
- They must have chosen
- Must have, yeah.
- Them on purpose, right?
There's no fucking way.
- If you're supporting artist,
you should change your name.
You should change your name to Bruce.
And no reason why, just do it.
- Yeah, but.
- Don't copy
my homework too hard.
(chuckling)
- I would be breaking it, if I got there,
they're like welcome The Ruse.
I'm like, "Check the ticket
right now, check it, right."
- Cause I literally went,
I literal had to go outside just to check,
that the main poster,
said Muse.
- Muse.
- Then like I was coming
in to see Muse perform.
I go outside and it is
like, "Yes, it is Muse."
Go back in, still the Ruse.
I was like, "Maybe they made
a mistake out front on the,
"maybe they got the
letters wrong, I dunno."
- I would be breaking,
I would be breaking.
- I mean, there's.
I've seen enough knock off
things in Southeast Asia
to be like, "Maybe they
just pretended to be Muse
"it's entire time."
- It's the Thai version of Muse.
That thing is stubbornly funny.
(Joey laughing)
- Oh my God.
- But yeah,
I saw them live and they were absolutely,
absolutely fucking incredible.
- So killing it.
- [Connor] I'm shocked, you
put the killers on here.
Do you like more than the one song?
- Do you like more than Mr. Brightside?
- Yes, yes.
I like.
- Ruby, Ruby?
- [Joey, Garnt] That's Kaiser Chiefs.
- Oh yeah, that is Kaiser.
- That's how little I
know about The Killers.
- Yeah.
- They sounds so similar.
- To be honest I,
to be honest, I only know Mr. Brightside.
- Do they have any other songs?
- Yeah, they have Mr. Brightside.
- Apparently their latest
albums really good.
They kinda launch like year, I think.
- I actually haven't
heard that latest album.
- Listen, why are they on the list, Garnt?
- Why are they on the list?
Because I think the killers
was my University life.
My university life.
I was actually like already
into The Killers before,
Mr. Brightside came to
takeover the UK scene.
- You were fans before they were popular.
- Well kind of, but they
also really just exploded
onto the UK scene with Somebody Told Me.
That was like,
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, that was real.
- That was like the first song
that really exploded.
And I was already into
Indie rock at the time.
And for the longest time,
I thought they were a British rock band.
- Everyone does.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're like a Mormon
American's, though.
- Yeah, yeah.
So like for the longest time,
I thought that they
were a British rock band
the same way as like Arctic Monkeys were,
and a lot of other British Indie bands.
Because they came out in that time.
But I didn't know they were from America,
but they were like the one
Indie band that I listened to
still throughout university.
Because the reason I stopped listen to,
listening to a lot of Indie music
is because my band broke up,
because we all went to university.
- Right.
- Right?
But, I listened to The Killers
and I don't know which
album is which songs,
but I know I listened to a lot of Killers.
See I'm drawing a blank right now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I just know I've listened
to a lot of Killers
and the real reason it's on here,
is not only because I listened
to them a lot in university,
but it's also the first band
that me and Sydney bonded over.
- Oh.
- Oh, so cute.
- So I remember, okay.
So, Sydney likes to quote a lot of songs
to a lot of people that
she hung out with, right.
And apparently she told me,
that the only time someone
had completed a song
lyric that she had quoted
instead of just being like Sidney,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Was when she quoted The
Killers to me via text,
and she was, she just randomly said.
Oh shit.
- Somebody Told Me.
- Not, Somebody Told Me, I Got Soul.
And I'd reply her back.
Fuck, fuck!
(all laughing)
Oh man, I'm.
- I reply her back, fuck.
And she was like, "Oh my God,
you're the ones Garnt I want?"
- Yeah.
- The absolute irony.
- Fuck me.
I'm drawing a black right now.
(clapping)
What's the.
- It's like I Got Soul.
Then you're just like,
- I'm not a soldier.
Is that the line?
This is like me trying to remember lyrics.
- I think it is I have a soul,
not I'm a soldier, I think.
- Cause I'm just like,
I'm just like I got soul, soul,
I'm not a soldier or something like that.
Okay, like I said, I
don't listen to lyrics.
Like I just, I just know.
I just knows,
- But you managed
to quote back that one?
- Yeah.
- Huh?
That's the one line he
managed to quote back.
- Yeah, that's the one line
I managed to quote back
and she was like, "Well,
you're a Killers' fan.
- You are the one.
- You are the one you,
you are the first person.
- You took a very big gamble
replying with that.
You gotta look like a fucking idiot.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, "What's wrong with Garnt?"
He said, "He's not a soldier
or something bizarre."
- Yeah, but yeah.
So The Killers holds a very,
you know, a very deep place in my heart.
Not only because I listen to The Killers
and I am reminded of University life,
but also because it's part
of the reason that I met
and bonded with my
partner that I'm with now.
- Cute.
- And I also saw them live
in Bangkok, Thailand as well.
(laughing)
It's so weird.
- You sure you want this?
- So we saw The Drillers,
we saw The Drillers live at Bangkok.
We're just construction team.
- Supporting act, The Fillers.
- We saw The Drillers.
I remember like the first,
I remember seeing them live
and the first song that they
played was Mr. Brightside.
- Of course.
- And obviously,
Mr. Brightside is.
- You gotta start us strong.
- Is the song that
everyone, everyone knows.
And I remember it such
a surreal experience,
just hearing a song that I'd listened to
so much in my childhood.
And it was almost like it was,
it was almost like a weird outta fuck,
outta fucking body experience.
Where I had heard the song
that meant so much to me
when at one point in my life.
And I saw them now at the age of 25, 26
or something like that, like way later.
And it just like a wave of
just like, it was so surreal.
Cause at what,
it was a wave of memories and nostalgia,
but also like me living in the moment.
It's so weird to describe
because just hearing them live
and hearing, it was like
my life had built a up
to this one moment,
I don't know.
- Beautiful.
- Because I'd never seen a band
that I loved so much as a kid,
later in life until that one moment.
So it was just such an
incredible moment for me.
I will never forget hearing Mr. Brightside
for the first time in life.
- A live.
- [Joey] And then we
have a Michael Jackson.
- Okay, so.
- I mean, I also like Vanilla.
(men laughing)
- Okay, so the reason that
Michael Jackson is on there
is because, so as a kid,
I went through a phase
where I was.
- Yeah, you spoke about this.
- Yeah?
- I think you have.
- Really?
- I feel like I've.
This is weirdly familiar.
Garnt talking about it.
- On the podcast?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I dunno if I have
talked about it on the podcast,
but as a kid, I went
through this massive phase
where I was obsessed with Michael Jackson.
Like I was a aware.
- You've definitely said this.
- Really, I dunno.
- I dunno if I've said it
in private to you guys or on the podcast.
But like, yeah.
I went through a phase when I was like,
just an obsess Michael Jackson kid.
- I think everyone's
gone through that phase
at least once.
- As a target, obvious once.
- Yeah.
(burping, laughing)
- This was the, okay.
This was before that phase.
But regardless of what his image was,
or what happens later in life,
there was, I think you know,
his music fucking slaps.
- Yeah, of course.
- It's like, yes it's vanilla,
but it's a classic for a reason.
- I love the song, pretty
young thing, but it's so hard.
It's so hard to listen to that song.
(burping)
- Like the lyrical content.
- You know how I like, they're
like separate the art artist?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I do.
But sometimes, it's
really fucking hard to.
- Yeah, that song definitely didn't,
- That's one of those songs, I'm like,
"Why, why?
"This song is so good, but
why do it have to be ruined?"
I literally cannot listen to
that song without being like,
"This is great, oh, no."
- And then you remember what it was about.
- Oh, oh, fuck.
- MJ, I feel.
- But so many was songs
are amazing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- MJ is just one of
those artists that I feel
you could be at any party
or any convention in
with any amount of people that could have
completely different
personalities on everything.
The moment of Michael
Jackson song comes on,
everyone's unanimously like fuck it.
- Yeah, it's good, every song's amazing.
- I think we talked about this before,
but I don't think we'll ever
see someone that had the reach
or was as famous as Michael Jackson was.
- Oh, you're surprised.
- He was famous by standing.
I love that.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Because part of the reason
I go into Michael Jackson
was because my dad actually introduced me
to Michael Jackson.
I remember he bought like a VHS
of the top 25 hits of,
- Holy shit.
- I think it was a 25th anniversary.
- I wish I had like a deep
story of every single pick.
I don't know, I was like,
- This is, this is the reason
I had the picks, cause I was like,
"I dunno how to talk about the music.
"I'm just gonna talk about the stories.
- Somebody's watching
like Slumdog Millionaire.
It's like every single answer
has a goddamn 10 part back,
like flashback it is insane.
- So it's one of the weirdest experiences
where you go to the
countryside in fucking Burma
or Thailand or something like that.
Like they've never
experienced internet there.
They barely have electricity there.
You go to the transit slide
and even going in the middle of nowhere,
somehow there will be this one farmer
who will have this old
beaten up cassette tape
of like Michael Jackson Thriller.
- Of course, everybody likes,
- And like they will,
they will not know a
single word of English.
And they're like, "Oh,
you grew up in England,
"you know Michael Jackson,
you know Michael Jackson's
"Should I beat it?"
And I'm just like, we're in the,
"how has Michael Jackson,
"how does Michael
Jackson have this reach?"
- Well, he's the king of pop, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- For a reason.
- So, it's still like I'm thinking about
it still blows my mind.
Just how famous one person is.
- Yeah, that's right.
- I Think Thriller, even to this day,
is most sold album ever.
- [Connor] Mm, you think so?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Connor] Look, I said I
think so like I have any idea.
- [Joey] Which is like stupid.
- [Connor] It sounds right.
- It's like, by stupid, I mean like,
the difference between Thriller
and everything else is like stupid.
- Yeah.
- True, true.
- It's insane.
- Yeah, because like you know,
you could go to the bomb fucked
middle of nowhere in Japan,
- Yeah.
- And there'll be someone like
decrepit 70 year old lady,
you know, putting rice in the rice fields
and being like, "Oh Michael
Jackson, yeah, yeah"
- I almost de crap it.
(laughing)
This a piece of shit, old lady.
They're all useless.
(all laughing)
- Decrepit wasn't the right word.
- This poor old lady, what's her problem?
- I wonder.
- I'm just tryna
give you some rice.
Which Joey will say, will
taste the same anyway.
- It all taste the same.
- Yeah, who just like
knows Michael Jackson.
It's like it's just,
- Yeah everyone knows
Michael Jackson.
- It's ridiculous thing.
- Yeah, it's like weird
to think how someone,
one person got this
famous to so many cultures
and so many countries that
obviously had nothing to do
with the US or just even
listen to that kind of music
in the first place.
And I mean, yeah.
I mean, Thriller is like.
I'm not putting like Thriller on there
is kind of putting like fucking Zelda
or something as your favorite
video game of all time.
But I mean, it's one of,
it's one of the most legendary out albums
and he's one of the most
legendary artists for a reason.
And,
- Yeah, absolutely.
- And I was a weird Michael Jackson kid.
I actually.
- Did you learn
how to moonwalk?
- Huh?
- Did you learn how to moonwalk?
- I attempted to learn how to moonwalk.
- I think I could moonwalk at one point.
Actually it's like bullshit.
- I could moonwalk
at one point too, yeah.
- Could you actually.
- Yeah, genuinely, genuinely.
- Yeah.
- Did you figure it out by yourself or.
- No, I watched YouTube video.
- I Think I watched YouTube video.
- Okay, okay.
Because I remember trying to
figure it out as a kid, right?
Trying to figure out
how the moonwalk works.
Because.
- You know,
like frame by frame on the video.
Just like analyzing the moonwalk.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because as like a five, six
year old kid or whatever,
I was like, "I got this.
"Okay, this looks exactly
like Michael Jackson."
And it was only until like years later
when you YouTube existed
and YouTube videos existed,
did I realize that's this is not,
this is not how you do the moonwalk,
I was doing it wrongly.
- I was just walking backwards.
(both laughing)
- Literally, I was just like
walking backwards the inside.
So I'm thinking I look cool as fuck.
No, no.
- I tried to do like the
the leg like pop thing that he does.
- Oh yeah.
- I tried to do that as well.
- Tried to do that, and
almost dislocated my knees.
(all laughing)
I was like, "Ahhh."
- That's like, Joey became a
pensioner there, he was fine.
- I was like, "Oh, is
that why he shouts ahhh?
Because it just fucking hurts, right?
- Yeah.
- Are these Japanese artist?
- Yeah, so, okay.
- What?
- Fuck me.
- Hold on, just frothing
over Michael Jackson's,
just frothing up.
- So then you can add
that to the compilation
of Garnt tries to drink
like a human being.
So I guess, this is with the Mayo.
But this is more of where I put her in,
just because I feel like
she's a genre of music
that I have just recently gotten into.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And as with everything in my life,
somehow, everything always comes back
to your Domestic Girlfriend.
- Oh what the fuck.
(laughing, breathes loud)
- It's almost like I was
born for this moment.
(Garnt laughing)
- As I always does, right.
- Yeah.
- So I'm not sure what
this genre of music is,
'cause it's not really just J-pop it.
It's more of like.
Okay, so how I would describe it,
do you guys know what Utaite?
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- So Utaite is like, I
believe singers or musicians
who mostly originated
from Nico Nico starting,
who started off doing a lot
of Hudson named Nico songs
and stuff like that.
- Just like covers.
- Yeah, covers and stuff like that.
So a lot of these musicians who
came from the scene ended up
just like, I guess,
graduating and just made
started making their own songs
with their own original artists.
And there's this, I
dunno what the genre is,
but there's a lot of artists in this genre
that I got introduced to by the
Domestic Girlfriend opening.
Cause it's the, okay.
Domestic Girlfriend is
a very divisive show.
I know that.
- Really.
- I know that.
The opening fucking slaps.
- Yeah, the opening's amazing.
- The opening is fucking amazing.
- I don't know the opening.
- I'm not gonna even be able to attempt
to say it.
- Yeah, it's harder.
- It's not like the catchy
song, it is just a banger.
- Right?
- It's like (burping)
- I'll take your word for it.
- Yeah, yeah.
And that's how I discovered
that artist, Minami.
And Spotify recommendations,
YouTube recommendations.
- Of course.
- So I got really,
really into Minami and her songs
from the Domestic Girlfriend opening.
And that kind of
introduced me to this world
of artists like Zutomayo, Eve.
Who else is fucking?
Yorushika, I think.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Yorushika, yeah.
- Yeah, so how I describe them is like,
they are anime music
that don't have an anime
that they play to.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
Again, I've listened to this.
I didn't know their name.
- Yeah.
- But if you go to my YouTube,
you can see I've listened
to this person a lot.
It's just like that genre of like,
I'm making the anime in my head.
(laughing)
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm making this up.
- So like a lot of these
artists that I listen to now,
have now been picked up for
like animate openings, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- So I remember I got into,
I got into Zutomayo and
then I got into Eve.
And then I remember listening
to the Jujitsu Kaisen's
opening, when that came out.
For the first time in my life,
I'm just like, "oh my
God, I know this band."
I know it cause I've never
heard this song before.
But they have such a distinct style
that I had that moment
where I'm just like,
"I've been following them
"since they were
underground motherfucker."
(laughing)
- I said, I read The Manga, fuck it.
- Yeah, you're right.
- He waved that
in front of Jujitsu fans so fast,
like I know this song.
- Yeah, it is the equivalent of the,
I've read this when The
Manga wasn't big, right?
Because you know, because
there are so many artists
in this field that have now been picked up
for anime opening or ending and like,
there is this, there's
this feeling of like,
"Yes, you have music slaps.
"I'm fucking proud you."
- I'm validated for being a fan of.
- I was like that with Tosite Sigure.
- Oh really?
Like before they became
the cyclo pass opening
of the Tokyo Ghoul opening,
I was like, "I knew them before those."
- Oh really?
- [Joey, Garnt] Yeah.
- Damn, you before the movie?
- Before they're animate.
- But then, also a little sad
because now everyone knows Eve as,
"Oh, it's the Jujitsu Kaisen band?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh.
- I'm like, "No, they're
not just the Jujitsu."
- There's so much more.
- There's so much more than that.
Listen to the rest of their fucking songs.
So yeah, I mean this is,
I guess that's the kind of
music I listen to the most now.
That's like really?
- Really?
- That's like my Weib kind of.
- It's really big in Japan
right now, especially like
Zutomayo and Yorushika
and they're like, yeah.
- Yeah.
Daft Punk, I'm supposed to be
a Daft Punk
- Daft Punk.
- I didn't know, you're
a big Daft Punk fan.
- I am, I was a big Daft Punk fan
during like the Discovery album, actually.
And I'm thinking back and
a lot of my favorite songs
or a lot of my favorite music
have visuals to accompany them.
Like do you guys, do you guys, okay.
When you guys listen to
a song, do you guys like,
do you guys imagine a music video
in your head or anything like that?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- Depends on the song for me.
- I usually like what I'm doing.
- Like for me, if I can't connect
to a song unless I can
imagine kind of story
or some kind of visuals
to accompany that song.
And I feel like, I have
such a random song,
I have such a random
music taste because to me,
I don't really listen to lyrics,
but if a song emotes an emotion
or a visual image in my head.
Then that's when I get really
emotionally connected to a song, right?
And to me, how I discovered Daft Punk,
was I discovered it
through Intastella 5555
- You're so good.
- Which was a fucking amazing movie,
and it's also one of the few albums
I have listened to all the way through
based purely from that movie.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And from then on,
from watching that movie
and seeing the story that
they crafted from that movie,
every Daft Punk song I listen to,
I have such cool visuals
that go along in my head
that's why I became such
a massive Daft Punk fan.
- How did that even happen?
That I dunno.
Was it literally just the guy listened to
and was like holy shit,
I gotta make an animate to go with this.
- I think, yeah.
I don't know exactly,
but I think Musk Muto Deji
was like a fan of Daft punk.
- Yeah.
- And then they just worked
something out and then.
- Cause it's so good,
it's so good.
- Would like to know,
I would like to know like,
what kind of like fucking.
- What do I have to do to get
Musk Muto Deji to make music?
- Yeah, how did that connection happen
- I don't even know.
- Cause this was before
anime was even close to big.
This was, this was like
on the ground is fuck.
So,
- Yeah.
- Do you have a favorite
song from the album?
Mine always changes quite often.
- From, it's hard.
- From Daft Punk.
- It's probably Harder,
Better, Faster, Stronger.
- That's good song.
- Yeah, that's good.
- I mean, for me, it's like,
I know it's the vanilla pick,
but like One More Time
will always be there.
- One More Time is amazing.
- One More Time is great.
- One More Time
with Digital Love.
- I just finished
the Digital Love.
- My two favorites.
- Digital love is fucking incredible.
- Digital love is amazing.
- Digital Love's very amazing.
- And I think the reason I picked
Harder, Better, Faster, Stronger
was because I remember when
I first started getting to
AMVs and everyone tried to
make LinkedIn Punk AMVS.
I did nothing, but just
make Daft Punk AMVS.
That was me, man.
That was like eve, the rest.
- I already made an AMV.
- The rest of YouTube went through that.
The rest of fucking YouTube went through
a LinkedIn Punk phase.
I was here just like.
It was like the entire
Discovery Channel in anime form
aside from like, not even the movie,
but just like in Naruto
clips and or shit like that.
- And when you heard the,
the Kanye West remix.
That song, you're just like,
"Oh my God."
- I think that's how I heard that
before I heard the original Daft Punk.
- All right, I discovered
Kanye through that song.
- Huh?
- I was like, "why?
"Who's this guy?"
- That song grew up
- I was like, "who's this guy
wrapping over a DF punk song."
And then that's Kanye West.
- Ah, so good.
- It's like, at first I hated that song
because I'm just like,
"Why would you ruin
Harder, Better, Fasteer."
And then like, the more I
listened to it, the more I'm like,
"Alright, this fucking slaps."
- Oh, yeah.
- Kanye, alright.
You're a crazy motherfucker, but.
- He's gonna get big.
(both laughing)
I can feel it.
(laughing)
- I think this guy's gonna do stuff.
- I think he's gonna be quite noodle.
- And Arctic Monkeys, is
obviously British staple.
- Yeah, obviously, again, I mean,
I've already talked about my Indie phase.
I've kind of just, it
wasn't just Arctic Monkeys.
It was just,
- Everyone born around
our generation ish, British
loves Arctic Monkeys.
- Because if I would
have to say,
- Very normal.
- If I would have to say what my,
what influences I took when,
I was in my band, right?
It was bands like Arctic
Monkeys, The Klaxons, Strokes,
who else was like big at that time?
Razorlight.
- Oh wow, Razor I fucking love that.
- Also like Red Hot Chili
Peppers and Foo Fighters as well.
Just like, just like any.
- Everyone.
- Any Australia around that
time, White Stripes was massive.
- Oh, White Stripes as well, fuck it.
Yes I fucking loved the White Stripes.
I mean that slot is just there for,
just for just mid 2000s.
- Bruce Check, Bruce Check?
- Yeah, Bruce Check.
- Bruce Check, right.
Bruce Check.
- And then you got Pillows.
- And then I got The Pillows.
Well, I put The Pillows there
because I did go through a phase
where there was a lot of
anime music on my playlist.
- Actually, we've all been there.
Come on.
- Yeah, of course.
- We've all been there.
And I feel like.
- Joey was the animate man at one point.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah and
- Good old times.
- But back then, I didn't like,
I didn't look up the bands
behind the anime music.
It was just anime music.
You know what I mean?
And.
- My apple thing
was TV size bracket.
(all laughing)
- A lot of one minute 30 songs.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- And I remember Fooly Cooley
was the first entire OST
that I've like, I took this entire OST
cause every song in the Fooly Cooly OST,
because it was basically just
The Pillows album, right?
- Yeah, basically.
- It was just an album of The Pillows.
It was the first time where
I took an entire anime OST
and put it on my MP3 player,
which wasn't even an iPod.
It was like this like.
- An actual league MP3 player.
- Yeah, yeah.
It was like a knockoff cheap ass
Chinese MP3 player that I
can't even remember the brands.
Because.
- Probably,
it doesn't exist anymore.
- Yeah, it probably doesn't exist anymore
because I couldn't afford proper iPods
or proper branded MP3 player.
- I had one that was kinda
like shaped like a long pill.
It was like a blue pill.
- Yes, and.
- And then you could
put like an ox-corner.
It was like tiny, tiny screen,
and the name of the song will like scroll
across the screen.
- Same, same.
- Oh good times.
- Yeah.
- Kids will never understand.
- And I mean like The Pillows,
it is again kind of just like Japanese,
but also has certain like,
- I was this close
to putting The Pillows
on mine, but I didn't.
- Again, like the reason I
really loved that soundtrack
is because FLC is kind
of just like an AMV,
but just in animate form.
- Six season goods AMV.
- Is the second season good?
- It's good, but nowhere near as.
- It's not as good.
- I've never watched it.
- It has its moments.
- You gotta watch
the first one.
- But its like to me,
like 90% of why I love Fooly Cooly so much
was cause of The Pillows.
- Oh yeah.
- And the visuals were kinda like,
it was kinda like watching
Intastella 5555 again,
where I'm.
- So if you like the music,
you'll like the anime.
- Oh yeah.
- What if you're
into the music?
You're like,
- It's gonna be hard to
not be into the music.
- Right, I get.
- I mean it kinda sets
the tone of the entire show.
- That makes sense.
- There's a reason why
it's one of the most famous
anime OST.
- All right, yeah.
People never shut off about Fooly Cooly
and why it's so amazing and why should.
- But it's moments like
this where I was afraid,
whenever people were just like,
"Yo, well, let's pass your Score.
"Let's see what your music taste is."
And I'm just like, "Fuck man.
"How am I going to explain,
"yeah like TV size, Naruto opening five?"
Like, "What is that?
"What is that?"
- Yeah, but at least it was like you know,
hard, Cut & Dried, like J-Rock, right?
I was listening to like Lucky
Star opening with people.
I was like, "That's
even harder to explain."
It's like past The Yonks.
I'm like, "I don't think
you want The Yonks, man.
- I definitely listened to too much,
Hannah Montana at one point.
- Really.
- More than I.
- What?
- More than I care to admit.
- Hannah Montana?
- You always saying
like Best of Both, was?
- Then I was so obsessed
with Hannah Montana.
- Best of Both
was an amazing song.
- Yeah, was good.
♪ Best ♪
When I was like 13,
I was obsessed with Hannah
Montana and I dunno why.
So much to say, that one of
the first books I ever read
was Miley Cyrus's autobiography.
(laughing)
- Are you serious?
- I'm not kidding.
I'm not kidding, I wish that was a joke.
I wish that was those String of Rose.
- You're a hardcore Miley Cyrus, fan?
- For some reason I was
obsessed with the Disney Shower
when I was like 12 or 13.
- That makes sense, though.
- I think I was sold on the dream
that you can do whatever you wanted to do.
- Yeah.
- I realized that no,
it's not how it works.
Let me sat this
- And then you saw,
and then you saw how
Miley turned out, right?
- Yeah, it was a little.
(chuckles)
I was like there was just Selena
Gomez Women's Much Better.
- Switch Gears.
- Oh, Much Better.
I'm done with it this,
so what do you meme?
I dunno.
I dunno why I just liked it.
And also I like the music for some reason.
- I thought that was,
- It's weird how,
when you're 12 and 13
you're just fucking idiot.
- I was more obsessed with Hillary Dolph.
(Connor laughing)
- Hillary Dolph?
- Yeah, like more of the,
I don't know why?
- Isn't it weird,
I used to have those phases?
- Yeah, Miley didn't really click for me.
Hillary, I was like, "Yeah,
I can get behind this."
(all laughing)
I dunno why?
- I feel like everyone has that one thing
that they've shoved down
and their subconsciously has pressed it.
And they're like, "I never like this.
"If you say I did, I did not."
- It's so in-explainable.
Now that I think about
it, I was like, "Why?"
- [Connor] Dude, why?
I don't,
- Did I like Hillary Dolph?
- I cannot explain to you
why I like this?
- Was she like hot to me?
I don't know.
- I think I like the
escapism that it offered.
- Yeah, that could be it.
- When I was like 12 and 13.
Copium or something,
I dunno why?
- Copium.
12 Year old copium.
- What's wrong with me.
And now I'm this jaded British
man who likes beans on toast.
But back then I had dreams and stuff.
Business Channel.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] What the happened to you?
(blabbers, chuckles)
- Anyway?
- Animate does that,
animate does that too, man.
- Destroys dreams.
- I mean, that is my three by three.
I dunno if that's like random as fuck?
- Yeah.
- It makes sense.
- I mean like.
- It's gone, it's gone.
- I feel like I've talked
more behind the stories of,
the stories of.
- I just wanna hear
more about you being in a band now.
- Yeah, we need more of that
- How am I supposed
to live up to this?
- Stories about living
in the band to be continued.
Oh my God.
- How am I suppose
to live up to that?
- Who's gonna be next.
- [Joey] Oh my God.
- It's the Joey.
- No, one end of.
- It's Yoey, Yoej.
- Yoey, Yoewi.
- Yoehi, Ejiohj.
- Helm, upside down, sorry.
- Hill.
- Let's put Jerry's on.
- This episode is
sponsored by Magic Spoon.
- Guys, do you remember waking up as a kid
watching Saturday morning cartoons,
eating that nice bowl of cereal?
- I do Joey.
- Don't you miss that feeling?
- God, I miss it so much.
- But you can't really do it
as an adult anymore, right?
Well, Magic Spoon is the
cereal for you adults out there
who want some of that
nostalgia back in your life.
- Okay, can actually
start eating this now?
I've been waiting to eat this.
(laughing)
- Did you know that inside
of The Magic Spoon Cereal,
there's zero grams of sugar,
13 to 14 grams of protein,
- What?
- And only four net grams
of carbs in each serving
and each serving is only 140 calories.
Isn't that amazing?
- Did you also know that
they're KETO friendly,
Gluten-free, grain-free,
soy-free and low Carb?
- Honestly, no joking.
Me and and Sydney have
been obsessed with these,
which is why, I was hungry
so I actually couldn't
wait to start eating these
because these are actually really good.
- Well, if the boys haven't convinced you,
I don't know what will.
So if you want to get
your very own Magic Spoon,
click that link below
to grab a variety pack
and try it today.
And be sure to use the promo code
TRASHTASTE at the checkout,
to get $5 off any order or go
to magicspoon.com/TRASHTASTE.
And Magic Spoon is so
confident in their product.
It's backed with a 100%
happiness guarantee.
So if you don't like it for any reason,
they'll refund your
money, no questions asked.
So again, click that link
in description down below
and use coupon code TRASHTASTE for $5 off
or go to magicspoon.com/TRASHTASTE
to save $5 today.
Back to the episode is.
- It's our pretentious
music critic time, let's go.
- [Connor] Hold up, can I guess these.
- [Joey] Please guess them.
- [Connor] This is okay.
I know this one.
This is from that one
video where I was like,
"This is your Rapper's favorite rapper."
(both laughing)
Dr. Doom.
- It's MF Dom.
- Yeah, that's Dr. Doom.
- Yeah.
- Dr. Doom, yeah.
He got his doctorate.
- I know that unfortunately
he passed away,
not too long ago as well, right?
- Yeah, he died of COVID.
- Yeah, actually.
- Oh wow, fuck.
- I recognize Radiohead.
- Yep, that's Radiohead.
- Yeah.
- I almost dunno who they are.
- I mean, he's gone on a TV show?
He look, I feel like I've seen him on TV.
- Tommy Hawk, been on a TV show?
- Sure, I don't know.
- To be honest, can we Google that?
Am I going crazy?
- Maybe, I don't know
- Can I even guess?
- Please.
I'll be surprised if
you can get anyone else.
- Streaked Out.
- I know one of them.
- Streaked Down
- Is it Streaked Down?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I know one of them's Tool.
- Yeah, that's Tool.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- Fuck, why do they all look the same?
Is this a British Bands?
- Yes.
- It could be like The
Who or The Sex Pistols
or it could be one of them.
- It's not Who or Sex
Pistols, but it's that era.
- Yeah, I feel like
they all look the same.
Okay, I'm British they all
look exactly the fucking same.
- That is true.
- They do, they do.
- Okay, so from left to right,
we got Tool, Led Zeppelin.
- Okay shit, that one was just
gonna kill me.
- Radiohead, Tangerine Dream,
Pink Floyd, Nick Drake, MF Doom,
American Football and Might June.
- My brother's gonna kill me.
He actually is obsessed
with like Led Zeppelin.
- Really?
- Yeah,
he was obsessed with them.
- I'll be his friend
- He loves all of those.
That era bands,
he know them really well.
- I could have put like nine,
just '70s hard rock bands
as well, if I wanted to.
But,
- Cause,
I love a lot of the music,
but a lot, at the same time,
I have no idea what any
of the band's look like.
- Like you know.
- That's what they look like.
They all look like long hair.
- Like Led Zeppelin,
I know what Aussie Osborn looks like now.
- [Joey, Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't know what he looked like,
- He kind of.
- Boy, he looked so different back then.
- Yeah, y'all Aussie Osborne
actually looked like a human.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- Poor 80 year old Japanese,
so now that the Aussie's getting dragged,
to be fair, Aussie is aged strangely.
- Yeah, when I saw him live, it was weird.
- Aussie is like, you know
those time lapses of like
this chicken nugget, has been
in the closet for 70 years
and hasn't aged, but it has.
And that's how I feel.
I don't know why, is
that a fact comparison?
I don't even know.
(both laughing)
That's how I feel.
It's like, "It shouldn't be alive,
"but it looks worryingly well."
- Yeah.
- Aussie now kind of looks
if someone took Aussie Osborn
and deflated him and then
reinflated him again.
- He's the one who's done.
- He looks like
if someone took Aussie
Osborn and just like,
he left him in water for too long.
(laughing, clapping)
- Poor Aussie.
He had like, just hasn't he
done like an insane amount
of drugs or something.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, he should've
- I mean most.
- He should have died ages
ago, normally, but he some,
I mean, that's why he can barely talk now.
- That's crazy.
- Like when I went to go see
Black Sabbath live,
it was like you know,
the original lineup.
- I'm surprised
he's still performing.
- Yeah.
I mean, this was like
maybe five, six years ago.
And it was labeled there Last Tour, right.
So I was like, "Of course I have to go."
- That's impressive, that
he's still able to perform.
- Well that's the thing.
It's like, he came out from.
When they all came onto stage
and the music starts playing
and you just see this guy
just like hobbling
across the stage, right.
And I'm like, "Oh, that's him.
"There he is."
And he just goes up to
the mic and he is like,
"How's y'all, how you doing?"
(both laughing)
I was like,
- That is normal for Birmingham.
What you talking about?
And I was like, "Ooh."
- Sorry, I break again.
- "I don't know what you saying man, but,
"God, you sounding good."
And he is like, "Oh, I'm
good but what's this job,
"Oh, I think you know it.
"General's gathered."
And he just starts singing normally.
I was like, "Why can you not?
"Why can you sing completely fine.
"But you can't talk normal."
- This is the, you haven't
lived in the UK test.
I can understand him like perfectly.
(laughing)
I'm not even joking.
(cameraman laughing)
I could understand what he was saying.
I don't know what it is, man.
The UK is weird.
- It's such,
- It doesn't make sense.
- It gives you like,
it's like the hard mode of English,
you know what I mean?
- I feel like,
- Once you're trained
in it, then you could,
you could like distinguish any accent.
- No, difficulties
understanding English accents.
Cause I just grew up
around really strange ones.
- But I guess like Black Sabbath,
Like sorry, Led Zeppelin for me,
is kind of just all of the
British, '70s hard rock, man.
So like Black Sabbath can fit in there,
Like Deep Purple can fit in there.
Cause like that's just
like the music my dad
just grew up with.
And he was like here, "Do
you know, Rolling Stones?".
And I was like, and I was
two years old and I was like,
"What is a music?"
And then he just played Rolling Stones.
And I was like, "Okay,
I can get behind this."
And then I think the first
band I like really connected to
was Led Zeppelin.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like I fucking love every song.
- Okay, I'm gonna, I'm like an idiot.
Are they the ones who
did Stairway to Heaven?
- Yes, they are the ones
who did Stairway to Heaven.
There's no way I could get,
that one wrong
- Stairway to heaven,
Rock and Roll, Black Dog,
- Immigrant Song.
Do you know that song?
The one that goes like,
(blabbering)
- Oh, yeah I get, I listen to that one.
- The Viking song.
- Yeah, they're the ones.
- Yeah, The Viking song,
that's them.
- I often living in Japan,
you'll meet like, let's
say, you're just me,
talking to Japanese people, whatever.
And they'll be like, "Oh,
I love British music."
I'll be like, "Oh, okay."
I'm thinking like, "Fuck, watch Era,
"they gonna talk to me about it."
Cause I don't know any of them.
It's always like Black
Sabbath, Led Zeppelin
and they'll be like, they'll ask me,
"Oh, what's your favorite song?"
I'll be like, (breathes deep)
- Stairway.
- Stairway to Heaven.
- This is where I feel like
this is where like my bullshit
levels come into like,
"how well can I do this?"
- Yeah, this.
- This is really wrong.
- But basically like, Jimmy Page,
Who's the guitarist for Led Zeppelin,
he's the one who basically
influenced me to start guitar.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- So I watched one
concert from Led Zeppelin
and I was like, "That is the
coolest fucking human alive."
Just like him just shredding on guitar,
I was like, "I want what
he has, I want that.
"Can I do that?"
- Is it a coincidence that
we're all posing very similarly.
And they just happen to all
have the same looking post.
- Yeah, I mean, that's
just like, we are a band.
- We are a band, we're doing pretty well
- Yeah, we are a band.
- Is he holding a door?
- What?
No, I think,
he's behind the door.
- He's behind a door.
(laughing)
- He's not holding a door.
He's not holding a door
in this thing.
- He's just holding door.
- I'm taking this home.
I'm taking.
- Yeah, so I guess like,
so Led Zeppelin is just like.
Just my love for like '70s rocks.
So like Black Sabbath, Deep
Purple, Rolling Stones.
Cause like the,
- This must have been
really hard for you to decide.
- It's really hard.
- Cause your music knowledge is vast.
- Yeah, it is.
- And I feel like
you have an appreciation
for music way beyond
anything me and Garnt have
- Yeah, for like me and
Connor like a music puddle.
Yours' like a music ocean.
- You're right, basically.
And then I guess like
kind of in the same vein,
but I had to like put it,
differently as Pink Floyd
in the middle.
- Right.
- You love them.
- I think I went to a
concert of Pink Floyd's.
Well, technically just Roger
Waters and he performed there.
Pink Floyd has this album called The Wall.
- Yeah, good take though.
- Which is considered like
one of the greatest concert albums.
- Joey has explained The
Wall to me in great detail.
- I like how you said,
"They made this album called The Wall."
- The Wall.
- Like it's not
one of the most favorite.
- I don't know,
- The favorite albums there.
- Because people always think
like, "Oh yeah, they made
dogs out of the moon."
It's like, okay.
- That's the one I knew.
- Oh, is that the one that
Nostalgia Critic's made, right?
- Yeah, my favorite, Nostalgia Critic's.
I love them.
- I love that album.
- It's amazing.
- Amazing.
I fucking I Nostalgia Critic's.
- But so Roger Waters was the guy who like
mostly wrote The Wall.
But the entire band did it as well.
But he went on like a tour all
around to perform The Wall.
- Yes.
- And so I got tickets to it,
like miraculously from a
friend of mine and I was like,
"Oh my God, my dream's
gonna fucking come true."
Like I get to see one
of my favorite bands.
But it wasn't a concert.
It was a Stage Show.
- Huh.
- So again, the whole
concept of The Wall is like,
guy creates a wall,
that's like not physical
and then he breaks it down
to get over his musical
and emotional bears.
Super oversimplifying the album.
- Okay, thank you.
- That's what I mean.
- Strait run.
- But what's amazing,
what was amazing about
that concert is that
as they are playing the
songs throughout the album,
they're literally physically
building a wall on stage.
- Oh, that's cool.
- That's cool.
- With like, it not obviously
not outta bricks, but like.
(both laughing)
- Like big, like Styrofoam Bricks.
- It's cool.
- So like after every song,
the band members actually
like go off the stage
and like place bricks on the wall.
- That's cool.
- And then, in the second half,
and then in the first half of the album,
he finishes building the wall
and then it just goes into an interlude.
- Is it funded by Donald Trump.
- Yeah, definitely.
He was like, "I want it taller."
(laughing)
And then, the second half
the wall is built, right.
But they build it in front of the band.
So as the concert is going on,
you can see less and less of the band.
- That's so cool.
- And then the second
half of the album starts,
the entire stage spins around.
- That's why we're looking for them.
- And so now you're looking
from inside The Wall.
- Huh.
- And then, because that's the theme
of the second half of the album.
And then at one point in,
at the end,
- How the fuck
do they spin the stage?
- It was all just on this like giant,
like Lazy Susan Esque,
like just rotating thing.
- Huh.
- Right.
- And then, like the second
to last song on the album,
the main protagonist of the
album, he breaks down The Wall.
And they literally like blow the shit up.
- That's so cool.
- Just the pieces,
just go flying into the crowd.
- That's fucking cool.
- And then,
the album just stands.
And I've never cried during a concert,
but that was the first
time I was like crying.
It was one of those
concerts where it's like,
you know normally, like
say if you go see Muse
or like Pendulum, right?
- Yeah.
- You're like standing up,
you're like grooving,
you're singing along,
you're like fuck, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You know like that kind of thing.
That was the first ever concert I went to
where I was just like
my ass firm only planted
on the seat and just staring.
- Right.
- Yeah, I appreciate it.
- And just listening and taking it in
because it's like,
- I wish I could have that.
- Because it was,
- It was crazy, it was like one of the,
I've been a lot of concerts in my life,
but that was like one of
the most like ethereal
is like the only way I could describe it.
It was just so like, oh
my God it's so magical.
- Well, as someone who doesn't understand
a lot of like the deeper appeal of music,
like what makes The Wall
such an amazing album?
Because to me, The Wall is
just like the album you say,
if you want to impress a dad,
you know like you meet,
- That's true.
- You meet your girlfriend's
dad or something.
And you're like,
"Oh what music do you like?"
- Cause it's like Craft Juliet
- I like.
- I love The Wall.
- I love Pink Floyd, The Wall.
And like easy fucking
bragging points, right?
- Yeah, of course, of course.
- I love IPAs, I love that.
(all laughing)
- IPAs, I love The Football,
- I do love IPAs.
- And I love The Wall.
Okay, so I did like a whole
dissertation on The Wall.
- [Connor] Huh?
- I did like a fault, so I
took music is like a major
in high school.
- Right, right.
- Cause I wanted to like pursue it at Uni.
Obviously, I didn't end
up pursuing it at Uni.
- Your dad's were like, "No,
no you're Asian, Jerry."
- Yeah, yeah, like, no,
way you're gonna do it,
you're gonna do it right now.
And one of like I did, I
studied like musicology,
which is just like music
analysis basically.
And they were like, and like
the yearlong dissertation
was take an album and just
write a dissertation about it.
Like write an album, write
an album review, basically.
I wrote this like 40 page,
dissertation on The Wall.
And like, what's the most
insane thing about The Wall
is like not just the fact
that the story is cohesive
and all the songs flow together?
- Hmm.
- Yeah.
- There is no pauses
between any of the songs
as it flows from one song to another,
the entire album is connected
to just one big song.
But the most amazing,
like mind blowing thing
is the fact that the album
literally repeats endlessly.
- That's cool.
- Right, right.
- So the end, the ending of the last song
fades into the beginning
of the first song.
- That's really cool.
- Okay.
- And that just completely like,
and that's not just a stylistic thing.
- No.
- They did that on purpose
to show that like what this
main character is going through.
Is a never ending cycle.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Right, right.
- And it's just never,
it's just constantly
repeating over and over.
- Tyler created that as well
with one push album.
- With Eagle, right?
- Yeah, Eagle did that as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
So The Wall was, I'd
say was the first album
to incorporate that style and a lot of,
obviously like Tyler and like
a lot of artists took that.
- Yeah.
- But like, yeah.
I mean, you know I've always said that,
you can make a concept heavy album, right.
And try and tell a story.
But if the music sucks,
then the music's gonna suck.
- No one likes the song because.
- It's you could have the most
like deep ass message about like,
whatever the you're trying to sing about.
But if the song doesn't stick with you,
then it's like there's no point.
The Wall though, it's like
every, song's a fucking banger.
So even if you listen to
it individually, it's like,
"Oh, it's a fucking great song."
- [Connor, Garnt] Yeah.
- It's it still slaps.
And then on top of that, it's like,
"Oh, it's deep as well,
and profound it's lyrics."
It's like, "What more could you ask for?"
- Yeah, awful and true.
- And like what?
The one thing though that
annoys the fuck outta me
is the fact that another brick in The Wall
is from this album.
And it's like Pink Floyd's
most well known song.
- Yeah.
- Right.
Just because, and I'm like, it's a Bob.
But so many people just
listen to it outta context.
- They don't know what it means.
- Because they don't know what it means.
Because if you actually in.
- It's pretty me.
- Yeah, yeah.
Because in the context of the album,
it's a really depressing song.
But it's just like played in an upbeat
and it's like a great song, right?
It's like I'm not gonna
fault them for that, but.
Yeah, I don't know.
And like all their albums
are just like that.
They've never had a
bad album, it might be.
So there's that.
- I know you love Radiohead an awful lot.
- I love Radiohead as does Garnt.
- Yeah, I do as well, he was,
- I know he was burnt over radio.
- [Joey, Garnt] Yeah.
- I remember like, I had to
pick between Muse and Radiohead
and I was just like, Muse can slightly,
just slightly edges them out.
- Is there's any Radiohead
songs that I've heard
that have been like, "I love this song?"
- Have you listened to Creep?
- I don't like creep that much.
- The best song.
- You guys always sing it.
- Well, I mean,
- This is like,
it's like the songs.
- Cause it's the least
depressing Radiohead song.
- Yeah, I don't really
like the depressing songs.
That's the Weeknd thing.
(all laughing)
- Cause at least it's gonna not be right.
- He plays (indistinct)
- He always sounds bumpy.
- It's cause I started
listening to the lyrics.
I'm not gonna do that
again, that was a mistake.
- I don't know like, I
think for me Radiohead,
what I appreciate the most
about Radiohead is that
they started off as
just like another '90s,
alternative rock band.
And then, one day they were just like,
"No, I don't think I will.
"I don't think I'll be another
'90s alternative rock band.
I'm gonna try something else.
And then, okay.
Computer came out, and it was one of
the most like revolutionary
'90s, rock bands ever.
And then, bands like Muse
listened to them was like,
"We can do that too."
- Yeah, exactly.
I think I,
- And like the Coldplay
as well was like heavily
influenced by Radiohead.
All these like big, old
alternative rock bands
that went a little experimental.
- I mean, I feel like Radiohead
are the OG in that sense
and they are fucking incredible.
And the only reason I
put Muse above them was
because I think I discovered
them both around the same time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But there are so many nights where
I just like conquered
just listen to Radiohead
and I don't know it's,
to me if I'm like having
an existential crisis,
I put on Radiohead, man.
Cause there's nothing that
just encapsulates that mood
more than just like a Radiohead song.
- It's like, "Sometimes I'm
just like, you know what?
"I just wanna stay home
and just feel depressed."
- I wish I could feel this
strongly about music, I did.
I remember I was at a place
that was like classical music being played
and there's this guy, I was enjoying it.
I thought it was amazing.
I was like, "Oh, this
guy's are so talented."
And there's a guy who's in the front
and I could see him
cause it was kinda like,
you know, a good circle, like semi circle.
I could see him.
And he was like tearing
up how good this was.
I remember thinking like,
"Fuck, how did he do that?"
- How did he.
- How does this mean so much to him?
Or how did that make him feel this way?
Cause I don't understand,
I like the sound a lot
and I really appreciated
the artistry and everything.
And I'm just like, "Fuck man.
"I wish I was able to
get what that guy had."
- I feel.
- I felt like shit.
- Was he emotional?
- About from the music, like
really made him emotional.
- I can easily get that.
- I can't get that.
- I think that's only,
I think there's only two.
- Am I fucked up?
- I think there's only two
artists in my three by three
that haven't made me cry.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I dunno.
Is that weird that I can't?
- I don't think it's weird.
- I wish I could get that to.
- To me I have a different problem.
Cause like I said,
I never know the deeper
meaning behind the music,
but like I've cried to so many songs,
I have no idea what they're about.
- Fuck.
- Cause they just make me
feel things.
- Yeah.
- I wanna feel these things.
- Why do they
make me feel things?
Like I don't listen.
I don't know what the lyrics mean.
I'm just like, "Damn man, this."
- I think like, have you
ever just like sat down
and just listened to music?
- Yeah, nothing.
- But I guess nothing,
but I guess you're listening
to like Daft Punk and shit.
- Yeah, I love the beat.
- It's nothing like Digital Love
isn't necessarily gonna make you cry.
- No, all right, you're right.
I don't know, all right.
I guess it's maybe the music I listen to,
the way I consume it.
- Yeah, maybe I dunno.
But I don't think it's weird.
I think there's a lot of people you.
- Cause I don't struggle to
when I watch TV or anything,
it's like super easy, I cry all the time.
- But there are people who like struggle
to cry watching movies.
- Yeah, it's true.
- So I guess it's the same thing.
- It's not like I'm
sitting there like (burps)
- Come on tears.
(moaning)
- I'm not there doing
that, it's just like,
I don't get what this guy's getting.
I don't understand why I, you maybe it's,
I don't know.
- No, no if.
- Maybe as I'm mature, I might.
- To me, music is, this's gonna
sound so philosophical now.
It's kinda like a language,
They're like,
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I don't speak it.
- It is like, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
I feel like there is
something being communicated
through the language of music and like,
I don't even understand
the words behind the music,
but I feel, you know?
There are times when I think
I feel the language behind it
and like the emotion that
being portrayed with the music.
It's so fucking weird.
- I mean, if animals or anything to go by,
you know, dancing is a language,
singing is a language,
somehow they don't understand,
but I imagine what they're
saying, but it does something
and that's how they
decided they, some animals
- It's just pulls out, like
just some kind of primal.
- Yeah, I think so.
- Yeah, you're right.
- I think we have an
inclination to a feel towards it
under where my, I fucked it up.
- I don't know what makes, I
don't what makes good music.
I don't know what makes
good music, like literally.
- I think what makes good music is just,
if it makes you feel a certain way.
- I watch like musical memes,
like memes that only people who like
or are really into music would get.
And I'm like,
"I feel like this is funny."
I just didn't, I just couldn't
understand why it was funny.
- Right, right.
- I'll be like when somebody plays C minor
or something like that
and I'll be like, "what?"
(laughing)
But yeah, that was kind of funny.
- That's a bit of a
deep cut, but you know.
- I don't if it is,
something along those lines.
- And then I guess Tool
is probably the one band
that made me love metal again.
- Okay.
- Because like I don't know.
- Twain Long in the songs?
(burping)
The name sounds extremely familiar.
- I mean, they
- Yeah, cause Joey
used to talked about them
- Cause I used to talk about.
- That's okay, that's probably, why,
that's probably, why.
- Cause I talk about them all the time?
But, I think, well, speaking
of like primal instinct,
I think like Tool does the
best job of like pulling out
that primal instinct in
people when they listen
to the music.
- I also I thought
you were talking about that band.
- No, no.
- I'm like Monkey.
(blabbering)
- I was like primal
instinct, I love that band.
- There's a band called
Primal Scream, which is good.
(Joey laughing)
But not primal instinct.
Yeah, I don't know like Tool is like,
I don't think they necessarily
have like a hit song or anything.
They're kind of like one
of those just cult bands,
I guess maybe like the pot.
- Sober, The Pot.
- Yeah, Sober, The Pot
Prison Sex, there's there's
a lot of like good songs.
But I think what makes it, like.
I think what makes Tool amazing,
what I feel love with Tool is that like,
especially this is a band that like,
you need to listen to the lyrics.
- Okay.
- Because it's like.
- Fuck.
- Not like it but what I
love about Tool is that
their music just in
general is so fucking good
that you'll still enjoy yourself without
listening to the lyrics at all.
- Okay.
- So like Maynard James Keenan,
who's this guy in the
middle, he's the lead singer.
In his, in like Tool Stage
Shows and like concerts,
normally the lead singer
is in the front, Right?
But Maynard for some reason is
behind a curtain in the back.
Like you can't even see him
half the time in concerts.
And that's because he treats his voice
as just another instrument.
- I know that.
- And if you want to listen in, closely,
on what he's saying, then you can.
If you don't want to, you don't have to.
There's the rest of the band to listen to.
And I think that's like, so
fucking cool because it's like,
again it goes back to
that whole thing of like,
you might have like some deep
ass message behind your music,
but if your music sucks, then
no one's gonna listen to it,
right?
- True, true.
And Tool's like, we can make banger songs
and we can make profound lyrics.
- That makes sense.
- And it's like, that's like I don't know.
It's just like musicians.
It's like, I inspire to be that.
And yeah, like I don't know.
Tool is one of those metal bands,
that even non metal fans love.
- Mm.
- I think every person I've shown Tool,
who is like not necessarily
into metal music,
is like, "Yeah, this fucking slabs."
- Oh.
- So like, I'd recommend,
if you don't like metal listen Tool.
- And then, oh God.
I guess we'll go to Dr.
Doom as Connor alluded to.
- MF Doom.
- I knew that, I knew
that I shouldn't have.
- So MF Doom, yeah.
As Connor said, is your favorite
Rapper's favorite rapper?
- Mm, I've seen that YouTube video.
- Yeah, you've seen
that in YouTube videos?
- I've, he's like a legend.
I've heard so much about this person,
but I've never listened to their music.
- Yeah, yeah.
So basically like Tyler The Creator
and like you know, fucking.
Literally every rapper, everyone
loves I and has gotten big,
has been somehow inspired by MF Doom.
Just because he's like, I dunno.
He's like the hiphop fans,
hip hop, if that makes sense?
- Yeah, exactly.
- Because I feel like
before MF Doom, the only hip hop
I ever really listened
to growing up was Eminem.
But that's because Eminem back then
was like fucking inescapable.
During Eminem show era,
Eminem was everywhere, right?
So I feel back then, I didn't
really take hiphop seriously
or like rapping seriously,
other than Eminem.
But then I listen to MF
Doom, and I was like,
"Okay, hold on, this might actually,
"this might actually be good.
"This might be some good music."
Again, another artist you
need to listen to the lyrics.
So.
- Yeah, I remember that.
I don't know who broke that music?
Vox or something.
- Vox did a video on it,
- I think they did
break down the lyrics.
- They did like an Elon video.
- On and I was like, "This is amazing.
"I just don't, I don't know."
- Yeah, I just,
- I dunno.
- I don't think I could
ever garner this by myself.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or even become close to
garnering this by myself.
- It's like, when they tell
you why the piano is amaz
or this specific piano is amazing.
I'm like, "I'm sure it is.
"It certainly looks the best."
But I don't know.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, it makes sense, it makes sense.
I mean, it's just like
good music in general.
Again, I'm having a hard time explaining
why this is good to people
who aren't on the same wavelength.
- Well, well,
- Well, luckily,
any hardcore music fans here
can appreciate your taste.
I'm sure.
- You're right, yeah.
- Well, well, okay.
If we were more hardcore into music,
how would you explain it then?
Cause I am curious.
- Okay, so.
- Break, it down for me.
- Break it down.
- Break it, break it down.
- Focusing a 100%.
- Break it down.
- Okay, so Tool, for example
is like just the sound
and their singing style and
the way they structure songs
it just has like a flow to it.
One song could have like
seven or eight different parts
that sound like seven or
eight different songs.
But somehow they can stitch
that bitch up together
and make it sound so
cohesive and like together,
to the point where you can listen through
a 15 minute Tool song and
it'll sound like two minutes.
- Yeah, I was gonna ask how
long is a typical Tool song?
(Garnt laughing)
- They're not actually too.
I mean, they obviously have
like long songs as well,
but I think average Tool songs,
maybe like five, six minutes.
- It's quite long.
- Which I guess is long.
But I mean like, if you
compare it to like say,
I don't know, a Tangerine Dream song,
like a standard Tangerine Dream song
is like 20 minutes.
- That's a good name.
- Yeah, so.
- I've never heard of them,
but that's a good name.
- So Tangerine Dream is this German group.
- Tangerine Dream?
- Yeah, Tangerine Dream.
- That's a good statement you
don't have to say anymore.
- It's a great fucking band name.
So they're a German group that like,
does electronica and ambient music.
And I put them there because
this is the one group,
I used to listen to all the time
in school while I was studying.
- How did you find out about this band?
- Right, its incredible.
- My dad showed them to me.
- Oh, okay, I was gonna say this.
Seems like very big.
- So basically every,
I reckon everyone except
maybe the bottom three here.
I found out through my dad.
- Okay.
- Right.
- So like he, yeah, he just.
- Yeah, he raised you well, man.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- But he's proud of you.
- Yeah.
So Tangerine Dream have been around,
they're still around, actually.
They've been around
like 60 years is almost.
- Fucking hell.
- I think they've been
around since the early '60s
and they're still going.
- What?
- Yeah.
- [Cameraman] 1968.
- Fucking hell, what?
- And they're still, they're still going.
They have like.
I think they have like 400
studio albums or something.
They have a big, big, big catalog.
Like it's stupid amount
of albums they've made.
But like basically they've revolutionized
like chill electronica,
meditation music, ambient music,
that kind of stuff.
And it's like perfect study material.
- Huh.
- Because it's like,
there's no lyrics.
- Better than Lo-fi better?
- Better than Lo-fi.
- It should be that Lo-fi hiphop girl.
Is it full shit?
- Lo-fi hip hop girl
wishes they were Tangerine.
(chuckling)
But yeah, I don't know.
It's just like really good like.
Tangerine Dream I would say
is like perfect background music.
If you're at like, you know,
if you have like friends
over and you're just like,
you just wanna like hang out
or you're like you know,
you have your fucking like,
I don't know, fiance's parents over.
And you don't wanna sound,
you don't wanna look
weird by putting on Tool
in the background, you know.
Tangerine Dream is like the music to go.
- Right.
- Because it's just like,
it's just relaxing, it's
inoffensive, it's just.
- I'll check it out.
- Yeah, and they got a lot of good songs.
They did a lot of movie soundtracks.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, so,
- Any movie song I know?
- There was this.
What was the Tom Cruise movie
that they did the soundtrack to?
- [Cameraman] Jack Reacher.
- They did a lot of soundtracks though.
And like game soundtracks
as well that they're done.
- Oh, what?
- Yeah, yeah.
So.
- What kind of games?
- I wish I could tell.
They've done, they've done 400 albums.
I don't fucking remember.
- What?
- [Camera Man] Risky Business?
- Risky business, yeah.
They did the Risky Business soundtrack.
- Oh wow.
- Which is like probably
one of their best albums.
They literally just three German dudes
who play a lot of relaxing music.
- Goddamn, they've got
a fucking work ethic.
- They've gotta work ethic.
- Fuck me!
- And then I guess Nick Drake is this guy.
- Who's that?
- So Nick Drake is like,
so he's like kind of,
he plays folk music.
- Okay.
- As if you couldn't
tell from this picture.
(Joey chuckles)
But he basically.
It's really hard to describe him.
So he basically,
he killed himself very early in his crew.
- Okay.
- I think he was like 23, 24
when he killed himself.
- Oh, Jesus.
But he made this one
album called Pink Moon.
- Yeah.
- And it's literally
just him and a guitar.
- Yeah.
- That's it.
And it's like super Lo-fi.
It's just him just like
singing just one guitar.
Occasionally, maybe like a piano.
But it's so like, it's one of like, look,
when it comes to depression,
as a theme in music.
- Yeah.
- A lot of artists have done it.
- Right.
- Like all sorts of different angles.
In my opinion, Pink Moon,
is probably the most fucking
hard hitting and like real album
when it comes to depression
and exploring depression.
- What makes you to say that?
- It's because it's not only
just the tone of his singing
and just the fact that
it's just him and a guitar,
- Yeah.
- But, again, it's like lyrics obviously.
He has this one song called,
I think it's called Black Dog.
And it inspired a book called Black Dog.
- Great.
- Where it's like,
depression is like a black dog.
It just like keeps coming back.
And that's from the song that he wrote.
But it's like, I don't know.
It's like it's beautiful.
But it's like haunting.
- Yeah.
- It's like really
really fucking haunting.
And every time I play this album,
this is like a couple
of songs that I just hit
where I'm just like breakdown, crying.
- I guess, cause you
know the, you know what,
how real the stuff is.
- Well, when someone's
in that state of mind,
Sometimes it's like sometimes
you can't always express yourself
or communicate that emotion
without having a medium like
music or something like that.
- What I can say, is
that Nick Drake is music,
but what it's certainly
not is entertainment.
- Right?
- It is this.
- Or he has me pampered.
- I would dare say, it
really is the awesome.
It is just like, it is music
in its purest artistic form.
- Yeah, okay.
- Where it's like,
you don't put on a Nick Drake
album to fucking jam out.
You put on a Nick Drake
album to self reflect
and just kind of take it in.
- Yeah.
- And kind of you learn from it.
Because he was like,
he was super depressed.
I'm talking like mega, mega,
mega depressed from a child.
- I mean, I believe that.
- And you know,
and like it led him to take his own life,
even though he was like
extremely fucking talented.
He probably had a bright
future ahead of him
if he kept going, but.
- Depression was very hard to deal with.
- Yeah.
- So then he just kind of gained
a cult status because of that.
And my sister actually
like put me onto Nick Drake
because I guess she was
in a stage in her life
where she kind of was like in that mood.
- Fuck.
- Yeah.
- And it was like,
I feel like I found him
in like the perfect time.
And again, this is not an
artist I would recommend
to people who want bangers.
- Fuck.
- Well, I feel like that type of music
or that type of media
definitely has a place
because especially like when
you are in a dark place,
sometimes you're not
looking for happy music
or things to cheery up
or like listening to,
I guess someone who has been
in that same emotional state as you,
or maybe finding someone who you feel
is in that same emotional stage as you.
There's like a comfort knowing that
at least you're not the only one
who's feeling like this now.
- And when I was in that
moment in my life as well
and listening to Nick Drake,
I think this album cheered me up
more than any fucking album.
- Yeah, it's weird.
Cause when I'm really
depressed and really sad,
listening to depressing
music cheers me up.
- Yeah.
- Like listening to happy music
just makes me more depressed.
Cause I'm just like,
"How does, how dare."
- Why are they happy
and I'm not?
- You're probably depressed.
- How dare this beat, be
like upbeat and like happy.
How dare these people be happy,
but you listen to depressing songs
and I'm just like, fuck man.
I'm not, I'm not alone.
- I'm not the only one.
- Yeah, exactly.
That's the thing, is like I feel listening
to happy music while depressed
just does the opposite effect
because it makes you go,
how come they're happy, but I'm not.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You know, I can't relate
to this happy mood right now
because that's not where I am.
Right now I'm in this dark
depressing like somber moment.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I need something that can like,
you know, compliment that feeling.
- Yeah.
- So that's why I love Nick Drake.
And then yeah, I talked about MF Doom.
American football?
So they're pretty much.
I think there are a recent like addition
to my favorite bands.
But they made me fall in love
with this genre of music
called Midwest emo.
(chuckling)
- [Connor, Garnt] What?
(Joey laughing)
- What the?
- There is a genre of
music called Midwest emo.
- You know what people
say, genres out loud.
And I'm just think, "You're just lying."
(Joey laughing)
Like I just like.
- Like you know?
Like at this point, I feel
like music, most of all,
like people just make up genres.
- Oh yeah, of course.
Of course they do.
- It it's music most of all.
- Yeah, of course, ff course they do.
They're just like, "It's not punk.
"It's just some derivative of punk.
"We don't wanna be the
same as those punk bands."
- So what's so good about 'em man.
Why do like, is emo country?
- No.
- Emo Midwest.
Midwest emo.
- Midwest emo.
- How'd you define Midwest emo?
- What's Midwest?
- It is emo made by bands
who have lived in the Midwest America.
- So what is the difference
between Midwest emo and emo?
- Okay, so emo.
- In terms of sound?
- Okay.
- Is there a Southern emo?
(Blabbers)
- I'm sure there is,
but I wouldn't be aware of it.
So Midwest emo is like.
So basically these guys founded the genre
and like the Indie scene
for the past 20 years
has been just filled
with Midwest emo bands.
- It has?
- Yeah.
They're like, they're like,
- I have no idea.
- There's a lot of bands
who have gotten big off
like Band Camp and like SoundCloud
and like Spotify and stuff,
- Right.
- Just that are in this genre.
And it's like.
(burps)
How do I explain Midwest emo?
It's like Indie rock and
Math rock with folk music.
(laughing)
- What is Math rock?
- Oh my God.
- This's why,
I don't understand.
- How do you explain
math rock now?
- This is the problem cause every time,
I speak to people who really know music,
they start saying things to me,
I'm like, "You're just
lying, you just lying."
Like why isn't that on iTunes, that thing?
Am I stupid, like?
- It is on iTunes, probably.
- It probably is now, but to me it's like,
"Are we categorizing
music too much, like?"
- I mean, I guess.
But that's because I feel music
just in general has expanded
to so far that it's just like,
it's kind of a shame to
just throw it all away.
It's just rock or pop.
- That's true, I guess.
Maybe this is just my own
inability to understand it.
And so I'm just like, "why?"
- Well, I mean
It's the same thing with
like electronic music, right?
Like we have electronica, you
have house, you have trance,
you have techno.
- Yeah, I guess.
- Whereas someone who doesn't
like music will be like,
"It's just all electronic."
- It's just the beeps and the boobs.
- It's just the beeps
and the boobs, right?
So same thing with Mid.
- That's trash.
- So Midwest emo is like,
as the name suggests,
a lot of the lyrical
themes are very depressing.
But it's not like folk music,
like strictly.
- Okay.
- It's not like a Nick Drake.
It's like, there's a band behind it.
Usually a lot of the songs can be upbeat,
but usually the lyrical
contents are very depressing.
Hence the emo.
- So that makes the emo
when it's depressing.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It's kinda like, it's kinda like emo.
This is gonna sound really bad.
Midwest emo is like Nick
Drake, if you were privileged.
(Garnt laughing)
Like if you were like, if you were like
- I dunno if that's a hard tackle.
- If you like, if you like,
- I don't understand
a lot about music.
- If you were like,
you know,
- We're getting into
so many layers right now.
- Midwest emo is like
it's coming from bands
who're like have lived in the Midwest
in small towns where it's not like
they're born into poverty
- It's kinda shit.
- Yeah, it's just like they
kinda just lived in a town
that's in the middle of
nowhere in the Midwest,
- Right.
- not a whole lot to do.
- Okay.
- Except get sad about shit.
Because they don't
Because they have like,
- Because you're
from Minnesota,
- Suburban Emo?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It is like Suburban Emo.
That's the only way.
- I just made that up.
- It is, it is literal.
It is a.
- I just made a new genre
of music right now.
- It is emo rock.
- Yeah.
- With mixes of folk music for people
who live in suburbs in Midwest areas.
- I think I understand.
- Yeah.
- [Cameraman] Paramore.
- Paramore?
- Yeah.
- So Paramore
- Paramore, okay.
- Paramore kind of took Midwest emo sound
and put a little bit more
of like a punk twist on it?
- Yeah.
- You're right.
- So they're a little more like a upbeat.
But there's still like
the lyrical context of like Paramore songs
are still very much like,
I'm feeling depressed because
this girl doesn't like me
and she left me and you know,
- Yeah, true.
- It's like my town has nothing,
my friends have all moved
away, that kind of stuff.
- Yeah.
So American Football is that.
And through American football,
I found I've like, so,
you know how Spotify has that,
like Spotify wrapped.
- Yeah, yap.
- Midwest emo was number
two for me last year.
- Oh.
- And American Football
was a big reason for that.
- Wow.
- Because I just listened
to a lot of American Football,
- Used to that much.
- And not just American football,
- Got that outta influence?
- There's a lot of other,
like Midwest emo.
And I basically just found this large pool
of Midwest emo bands and
they're all fucking amazing.
- What appeals to you about Midwest emo?
- Yeah (chuckles)
That's such a random like.
- It is right.
- It's such a random genre of music.
- I don't know.
For one, the music is just good.
Like, it sounds good,
it's like performed well,
because it's got blends of math rock,
which is very technical
rock and technical guitar.
- Okay.
- I just love that sound in general.
Japan does a lot of really good math rock.
Japan has it's own branch
of math rock, called Japanese Math Rock.
And Japan is like really
fucking good at just like,
(blabbering)
Like Ling Tosite Sigure,
for instance, right.
like the opening psychopath
their first song?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, that's math rock.
- Oh.
- Where it's like very technical guitar.
- Didn't know that.
- And it's just like
very Whaley.
- Fair enough.
- But Midwest emo kind of
takes a lot of that style
of just like technical guitar,
which just as a guitarist,
I can appreciate for once.
- That makes sense.
- Like one thing
I always want to know is like,
how much do you appreciate
music in a technical sense?
Or like a theory sense, where obviously,
you're way more musical trained,
musically trained than say I am.
So how much does that play
into your taste in music
or your appreciation of music in general?
- I Mean if I hear
something I'm just like,
"Oh that's cool."
What did you just do there?
Then obviously I'm gonna
like perk my ears up.
But I'm not gonna fall in love with a band
just because they're technical.
- Right.
- That makes sense.
- Because again,
at the end of the day,
- It's feeling, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- If your music isn't good,
then it's not good, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know,
I've listened to a lot of Midwest emo
and even like metal, like
technical metal bands
or stuff like that where I'm like,
"Yeah, your technical, you are skilled."
But, the music isn't really
for me, kind of thing.
- Right.
- And then I guess finally,
is the only Japanese guy, is Maeda Jun.
He basically,
- That name sound familiar.
- Yeah, he wrote music
for like Kanade.
- He also wrote Kanade.
He also wrote
Kanade, Aaron Cannon.
- What?
- Yeah, and Angel B,
so basically every key.
- So basically,
what makes Maeda Jun,
- Is this cause
you got into The Gacha recently?
- That too.
But what makes Maeda Jun my fucking idol,
is just, again, the fact that
this man can single handedly
write a story, write characters
and just write all the music for it.
Just single handedly.
- It must be an advantage then.
You can like, you know the characters
in the story better than anyone.
- Right.
- You can craft the whole music.
- But I don't know like.
Of course I like, I look up to this guy
just for his ability to tell a story
because like Kanade and Aaron and Cannon
and angel beats are like,
you know, great stories.
But like, I think the one
thing that makes Maeda
like I appreciate Maeda Jun
is just how fucking
musically talented he is.
- Yeah.
- Because not only can he
write like somba piano tracks
that have no lyrics at all,
the entirety of the Kanade a soundtrack,
and make me cry like a fucking baby.
- Yeah, I cried, I cried.
- But he can write
fucking bangers as well.
Like you know, any of
the Angel Beats songs.
- Yep, yep.
- Are absolute fucking
like Girl's Dead Monster
that fictional band he
created in Angel Beats,
every song is a banger.
I'm like you can write bangers
and you can make me cry.
- It's pretty impressive,
I didn't know that.
- Like how do you do that?
- I didn't know that really.
- And so you were talking
about The Gacha Game I got into.
So Key recently released a Gacha Game
called Heaven Burns Red,
which is the first fully Maeda Jun
produced game in 15 years.
- Huh.
- And so he wrote the story.
- Is it a visual novel?
- It's yeah, it's kind of
it's very dialogue intensive.
Cause it's a fucking Maeda Jun game.
- Yeah.
(sniffing)
- But it's also like a turn
base RPG kind of thing as well.
- Okay.
- Of course it does Gacha.
- Of course.
- You know I've I love it.
- Kinda he's got his music?
- He wrote the story, he
wrote the character designs.
He came up with the character designs.
- Huh.
- He came up with a scenario
and he wrote all the music for it.
- [Connor] Fucking hell.
- Well, that's why he hasn't
been doing anime recently.
Hasn't he?
- Exactly.
- All this time in a Gacha Game.
- I mean, it's also because
he's been extremely sick.
- Yeah, true.
- As well.
- Oh man.
- Like the whole, you know
the whole theme in Angel Beats
about the heart thing, that's
just based off his own life.
- Oh, Jesus Christ.
- Because he has
- Fuck hell.
- A chronic heart disease
or something.
- This is a beast or something
He's done so much.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Jesus!
- I mean he wrote, I'm pretty sure.
I dunno if this is true,
but I think he wrote Angel
Beats in the hospital bed.
- Seriously.
- Yeah, while he was admitted to hospital,
he wrote Angel Beats.
- What the, what a bam
or something.
- And it's just, yeah.
And he's just like, he's a bam.
And the fact that like,
again, this man, doesn't miss.
Not just like he hate it.
- He don't miss.
- He don't miss, like every,
even in the new game, the story is great.
The characters are great
and the music fucking slaps.
- So I guess, I guess everything else
just lifts your enjoyment
of the music more.
- Right.
- And it's like okay, but.
- And I feel like, you
know we were saying earlier
that like Fooly Cooly as well.
- Yeah.
- Like pillows,
I was very close to putting
Pillows because that's just like
- Pitches it out for you.
- Yeah.
- I think Maeda Jun just
pitches it out for me
because as much as I love
the Fooly Cool soundtrack,
the first soundtrack
that made me fall in love
with soundtracks was Kanade.
Because like, again, as a pianist myself,
listening to like piano music
that makes me fucking break
down crying like bitch.
- Can perform it.
(sobbing)
- And it's like I can't even,
I can't even learn to play
these songs without crying.
- Right, right.
- And it's like that's,
- That's wholesome.
- And that's like really
hard to do as someone
who like you know.
Cause as someone who writes music,
I strive to do that to people.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- And the fact that this guy can do it
over and over, and over again,
with everything also writes is like,
"How do you do that?"
- I can murmur at all that talent.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- It's not fair.
- I'm just saying, man.
Key would not be where
they are without this guy.
- Hey, sometimes you see someone
and you're like, "You're
a bit too talented.
(Joey laughing)
- This is unfair.
- You're,
- And he's good looking like,
- Yeah, yeah.
- As if I couldn't like
give me something
to hate about you.
- God, obviously didn't love
all humans equally.
- No, true.
(Joey laughing)
- He made you.
- Hate Maeda Jun.
- He made on Maeda Jun.
- It's not fair, it's not fair.
- It's not fair.
- I wish I had a sliver of
the talent this guy has.
But I guess,
- That guy's so talented.
- That's my three by my three.
- I was very, I feel like I learned a lot.
I didn't even know anything.
- I learned way more than
me talking myself or listening to Connor.
- Oh, no, no, man.
I feel a little bit
pushback because I was like,
"I need to somehow top Garnt
living in anime, Beck story.
- You can't,
you can't top that.
- I couldn't top it.
So I was like.
- We call that
the Slumdog Millionaire.
Boy, we're just living in Garnt's life.
We're not, we're not in this.
Garnt's story is his own.
- I swear.
- I will forever live in that shadow.
- I swear, I have mentioned before,
I've been in the band, just.
- You've not, you've not.
- Yeah, same way everyone's
been in the band.
- Yeah.
- Like, no, you don't know.
- Why does that mean?
- I've been, I've been in like six bands,
but I never had a cool story like that.
- I thought when I said I was in a band,
everyone had similarly experience.
- No, no.
- It's not at all
- You're wrong.
- For example, what normally happens
when you're in the band then?
- You're just kinda like.
- You're not playing gigs.
- Pretend to
- Yeah, yeah.
You go to the drummer's house,
you play a couple of cover songs.
- That's it.
- And then you're like,
"All right, cool, see you never again."
- Yeah, that happens all the time.
You sing Smash Mouth once.
- What's the,
what's the point of forming a band,
if you're not gonna play gigs?
- I mean.
- How you,
how you gonna play gig?
How you gonna arrange that?
- How you gonna play gigs?
- You're like Trump
who's fucking dumb as fuck.
How did you get, how did you get a gig?
- That's so fucking easy in Brighton,
there's so many.
- Or girl?
- Oh yeah, in Brighton.
In Sydney, it's pretty fucking difficult.
- Cause there's
no music stage.
- Where's like fields,
where am I gonna perform, Garnt?
(both laughing)
where am I gonna sing
Smashed Mouth too?
- To the sheep.
- Where am I gonna sing, All star, Garnt?
Think about this.
- Look like five gigs
going on every weekend in Brighton.
I guess I did take that.
- I can't even top you when it comes
to like band names either,
because that band name is just like fuck.
The best band name I was
in, was Resting Bitch Face.
(laughing)
But that's just because
the lead singer had a resting bitch face.
- It's always like that,
it's like Chido Puffs.
Well, it's Chido, I always like it.
- Yeah, it's good.
- He's got battle in the ass in 10 years
and we have copyright fringe.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I'll just deal with it.
But damn, I guess that was
our Trash Taste in music.
- Yeah.
- Let us know down below whats
your thoughts about it, and.
- Who has the trashiest taste in music?
- Always that's me, thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
- Probably like,
I had a hard time explaining
why I liked my music.
- No, you did not.
Well, boy, you fucking hard about.
You did it perfectly.
- You had the longest segment.
- You literally had amazing stories
for every single reason.
- I literally just did like.
The thing is I didn't
even talk about the music.
- That doesn't matter.
- Yeah, but you had like
a kishimoto filler awkward
of stories for every
single band you about.
- Joey, fuck off, man.
Yeah, you should just fuck off,
messing with that shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, well, you know
who doesn't mess us with that.
The patrons.
- Hell, yeah.
- Who are scream now
- You're watching us now
- This guy has great taste of music.
- They love,
they love Midwest emo.
- All of these guys
have amazing taste music.
- Absolutely cracking taste music.
- But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then go to Patreon
@patreon.com/TRASHTASTE.
Also falls on Twitter,
and this means on the
sub-head @TRASHTASTEPOD.
Listen to us on Spotify.
- We're gonna make a new,
we're gonna make a new
genre of music right now.
- [Joey] We're gonna call it Trash Call.
- [Connor] Fat Fang.
- Yeah, Weib Call, right?
- Weib Call.
- Trash Call.
- I came out Weib Call.
(laughing)
Put that on the Wiki.
(laughs)
Coined the term Weib Call.
All right, see you guys next time.
- Buy guys.
- See you guys later.
- Bye.
(rock and roll music)